morning everyone welcome to Edna for the
committee next week we will be meeting
on Tuesday in the finance room for a day
of
hearings and Wednesday will be here for
full day of hearings on Thursday there
is a session that is not expected to
last very long and I'm thinking we might
want to have an executive session after
the house session I if so I'll be
announcing it from the floor but I
wanted to warn you before before doing
that
so um I'm hoping that we will continue
to be able to not meet on Mondays and
Fridays and so uh we in all of February
we will probably be meeting Tuesday and
Wednesdays maybe here maybe somewhere
else on Tuesdays and session on
Thursday and Mondays and Fridays are
always open for
subcommittees
just what
is we are are sharing this room with
election law and they are planning to be
here next Tuesday the original agreement
was that they would have Tuesday and we
would have the rest of the week and then
the speaker came in and said but I want
Thursdays and so we're getting
bumped not meeting joint with anybody no
no no we're just getting a that that
room was available so we will be
there well yes but
we I've planned out our hearings because
we've got so many
bills
and that's why I'm warning you now
February we will probably be here every
Tuesday every Wednesday for hearings and
that should get all of our all 66
bills the other
car it's all right um we got more than
expected more than uh than I want but
we've got them so we will do what we
can
so I will encourage people to
um think about what we could exec next
Thursday and I'll talk to all the
subcommittee chairs and see what what
they're through with so all right so
well opening the hearing on House Bill
1057 and I call Representative
PR
good morning Madam chair and the rest of
the committee good
morning uh back again so this morning
I'm introducing I'm Mark PR representing
Hillsboro 15 Manchester award 8 uh I'm
introducing
1057 which is uh provisional licensing
for emergency
medical um technicians
EMTs uh they added a new law a few years
back that every Mt once they complete
their course and they go for lure has to
go through a background check
everybody's getting a background check
uh we've had a couple of people who got
out of school wanted to come work for my
fire department so I I've experienced
this personally uh and it took them over
three months to get their background
check so here's somebody trying to get
into a new career to take care of their
family and they're waiting three months
obviously they couldn't wait three
months and they would and found another
job driving a truck doing whatever and
we lost that person and we're at
recruiting Fire EMS and police is very
hard and difficult now because not a lot
of people want those jobs so if we have
somebody interested we need to get them
in get them interested and hang on to
them so what this does is if after three
weeks they haven't got their background
check from from the state the state
shall issue them a temporary license
that they can revoke at any time like if
their background check comes with
something bad
um you know they can pull that license
and they can't work anymore and they'll
just call the employer and notify them
that their license has been revoked and
that person will be gone so you may hear
that oh background checks don't take
that long anymore they're down to two
weeks or whatever but what happens if
Department of Safety loses a couple of
people in that department and we're back
to three months again right so yes I
know it's working pretty good right now
but I'mma kind of like to have safeties
in place
that if it extends because even now
there's a couple that we've had recently
that took an extended period of time
four or five weeks granted that's still
not too bad but it
I hate to see it go back to the three
months so this being in place after
three weeks if if the state hasn't
cleared them they get a temporary
license and again if something comes
back bad they're they're
out and with that I'll end my testimony
and take questions okay thank you
representative
Schmidt thank you mam chair good morning
representative morning so I I I totally
get your position and in your
unhappiness with people who are
qualified ready to go and system hangs
them out to drve uh but what about this
the person who whose thing comes back
bad they've been working
potentially damaging people you you know
that what what I'm getting at so I'll
tell you that we work in pairs right so
if it's known that they have a temporary
license
I think we would pair them up with
somebody who's a pretty sharp person and
and keep an eye on them as
well especially if they have that
transitional
license that that's helpful no working
in pars obviously
thank working in Paris that
does mitigate the the potential danger
of having somebody who's incompetent or
correct and any any new EMT we watch
like a anyway right because they don't
have the experience so we're going to be
on them to begin
with not any different because of their
uh temporary thing but because we know
they're
new yeah and rep representative Schmid
this applies to people who have
completed the training and the test
right so uh and I believe there are a
number of other professions that issue
temporary licenses pending the result of
the criminal background check y right
well I the thing is yes representative
schm yes thank you thank you madam chair
uh I totally get the the the colic we
were having the issue is the the the bad
egg but but the fact of working in pairs
that mitigates that greatly so thank you
for the privilege of uh continuing thank
representative PR do you know how many
or what percentage of candidates fail
their background
check I do not but I don't think there's
many I I in recent times for me I've
only heard of one person coming back
with a little something that needed to
get dove into more okay thank you
because we found out that the licensed
nursing assistants 70% of them have it
issue for the for the board to review
and if that were the case I'd be much
more concerned yeah representative if uh
La us you had a
question okay thank you representative
sh it thank you madam chair um good
morning morning um even though you work
in pairs would there ever be an instance
where this individual would be alone
with um I'll call him a
patient so especially a new EMT we would
not leave them alone right the bus can't
the ambulance can't move Mo without two
people granted one has to be driving but
now in in all of our ambulances we have
a camera in the back okay right so my
rearview mirror becomes the screen for
the back so I can see what's going on
it's there for a couple reasons mostly
for safety if if a patient starts to
attack my partner I can see it pull over
and go help and things like that but
also if any wrongdoing is happening you
know I know I always watch that screen
you know when I'm driving to check on my
but and I would see everything that's
going on and you can hear what's going
on too okay thank you okay
representative Brown uh thank you madam
chair uh good morning
representative um maybe I'm
misunderstanding line
eight if it's I may not know the
language it's supposed to be written in
the sentence says a temporary
provisional license shall be WR revoked
upon the reced of criminal history
record check is that a term that says
it's I think if it came back bad it it
would be revoked that actually I guess
if that check when that check comes back
that license is revoked and a permanent
regular license would be issued followup
please please I understood that yes I
understand that's what it means but I
don't know that's what it says yeah I
get you thank you okay representative
laus yeah if I maybe I could help um
it's worded a little oddly but it says
that the license shall be revoked upon
receipt of a criminal history check if a
license denied under this section I took
that to mean if the criminal history
check resulted in the license being
denied then the provisional license
would be revoked maybe we worded better
but okay okay yes
okay yes representative PR we're we like
the idea but we're concerned about the
word smithing
issues that keep popping always it's
about the word smithing all right any
repr py thank you madam chair just to
clarify so once the provisional
license I mean rather background check
comes back irrespective of when it comes
between the time it is to how many so
the provisional license would be just
for 3 months the maximum time it would
take correct it's going to be until that
background check comes back right
because you want them to keep working so
if I put it at three months and it takes
four months for the background check and
three months he has to stop working and
wait for the background check yes that
that would be specified in the rules
that are authorized by The Bill
thank
questions okay thank you very much for
your
testimony is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on HB
1057 all right seeing none I will close
the public
hearing
executive okay we got
a okay we have a quorum so I'd like to
move into executive session and I'll
entertain a motion I'm sorry
representative she would had a question
for do you have a question I
was wondering hoping I think the
gentleman that's there is from EMS is
that that we're just wondering if you
really would like to speak to us
we're sorry I'll reopen the
hearing and introduce yourself please
thank you my name is Chris dewas um I'm
from Hollis New Hampshire and I am with
American Medical Response I'm also on
the board of directors for the New
Hampshire Ambulance
Association uh I I I generally believe
we support this bill there have been
occasions where particularly during
covid uh it was a very very lengthy
process uh and and listen I understand
why uh to get lure um but as
representative PR uh made mention of uh
it is very difficult to recruit and
retain employees in public safety and
Healthcare right now and we want to make
sure that every Avenue that is available
to us is being explored uh to try and do
that um as well we want to make sure
that our employees that we hire are um
appropriately vetted and that there are
safeguards in place for our patients and
our and our other staff um and I think
that there could be a balance um to be
able to do this with this
bill okay thank you are there questions
from the committee representative
manui does this include the students
that train right after for becoming an
EMT just
before applying for um those those
individuals don't need to be licensed
students um so this is someone who's uh
completed and passed all of the
examination requirements uh taking the
course pass the national registry exam
and is ready for ready for licensing and
and you know most organizations I can't
speak for all of them but at least our
organizations we do our own background
check on on people that we are hiring um
for a number of different things whether
it's criminal background check or uh oig
Medicare exclusion uh drug testing uh
you know the like so we're we're fully
vetting our individuals before they go
to the state um as well so okay thank
you for your testimony other
questions uh no we have private
ambulance services as
well could you kindly fill out a pink
card and bring it to us I shall thank
you thank you okay any other
questions all right all right seeing
none thank you for your
testimony anyone
else all right then I will reclose the
public hearing and
uh and mo go into executive session and
entertain a
motion I'll make a motion to autop
pass
okay do you to speak to your
motion this seems to be a reasonable way
of attaining
um support for the
EMTs and um a safe way to guard the
public at the same time so I think that
this is um helpful to the
cause
gold thank you madam chair my cousin is
the head of um of standards for EMTs and
her partner own an private EMT service
and I know the dedication and the um
just the the way they pay attention to
details and safety Public Safety so I
support this completely thank you anyone
else goalie thank you madam
chair I think this
is good piece of legislation it still
gives a 3-week waiting period giving
Department of Safety that ability to
complete the background check before the
license is issued um we've heard
that most of the backup was during covid
times when we all know there was a lot
going on um I think they are getting
better at what they are doing with these
checks and I'm hoping that you know this
will not only just speed up the
licensing process but um give a little
bit of time for Department of Safety to
complete those checks um and get this
person licensed
appropriately all right anyone else
represent Mani thank you madam chair
this seems like in any other par
professional professional where um
mentorship or
provisional licensing with um clinical
Fellowship that's what is coming to my
mind CFI for speech pathologist and
ideologist that is a time where you're
supervised you can't take on permanently
this gives you know they're already done
all the exams everything waiting this
help build their experience and I would
okay anyone else all right the motion is
ought to pass by representative Roa and
when ready CL and call the okay
representative luus yes representative
Bailey yes representative Boyd yes the
clerk votes yes representative Brown yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shu
yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative gold yes representative
Smith yes representative Mani py yes
vote is 13 to
nothing oh no it's actually you are the
13th I'm so sorry the chair yes
sorry it is 13 to nothing I counted her
before she even
voted
thank you representative Gera for for
reading my
mind all right uh does anyone object to
consent okay seeing none we'll put this
on
consent and we will take a 10-minute
break before the next
hearing
okay
m
good morning welcome back to
Edna I'm opening the public hearing on
House Bill 1233 and I call
Representative
Kelly good morning m mam chair and
members of the committee um I am Diane
Kelly representing Hillsboro District 32
and I am here this morning to introduce
um HB 1233 which originally some of you
may remember originally came to this
committee as HB 258 last year um and it
is basically allowing for um people who
chiropractors who are certified animal
chiropractors and who were certified in
a program that is um approved by the
director of oplc to be exempt from
Veterinary um lure requirements so that
they can work on animals and um the
subcommittee chaired by representative
leus and very hardworking members um who
were willing to show up and give their
extra time and and extra hard work and
everything to that committee were able
to get it amended in a way that worked
for all the stakeholders I think and and
um it's great bille but um I owe this
committee an apology I have a family
member who had an extreme medical
emergency last year just before the
Senate hearing and um I was so excited
to go there with it but I literally just
forgot I was dealing with
hospitalization issues and such and just
a lot going on so I did not show up so I
apologize for putting you all through
this again but um it is a great Bill and
um I I would like to shepher it through
again um it passed last year um through
this body on consent it went on the
consent calendar and then passed the
house on consent and uh yeah I just just
botched so um this year I don't care who
has a medical problem I will show up in
the Senate and
um representative Schmidt
please so um anyway that is what I have
to say and I guess there are some
speakers behind me to um also speak as
well unless there are questions for
me represent so can you tell us a little
bit about the changes that were made to
this bill from last years
and the the considerations that which
you participated in the study committee
I would imagine I I showed up for it and
maybe spoke a little more excitedly than
I should have um um probably
representative leas would would be able
to address that yes please
representative L yeah so we worked with
a number of the stakeholders uh that
board and other people and came up with
an amendment which passed this Committee
in the house and the bill is written
here is exactly the bill that is as
amended that came out of the
house that answers the
question all right any any other
questions yes it was thank you r
representative thank
you Aubrey fre
fredman Madam chair committee members uh
Aubrey Friedman I live in Bridgewater
private citizen who doesn't have a pet
now but hopes to have one soon again I
speak in support of this bill um the
thing is I think the licensing is just
not necessary the bill already specifies
to have a uh a nationally recognized
professional Trade Organization and
that's the entity that's going to do the
real policing in this industry um and
they they have very high standards and
they have the real incentive to weed out
any bad members so you know reputation
that's the main thing you don't want if
you certify members who do a poor job or
hurt animals or unprofessional unethical
whatever it might be that reflects
negatively negatively on everybody in
the industry so they have a real
incentive to weed out the bad apples so
they're doing the real policing now the
bureaucrats I have nothing against them
personally they are well-meaning but
they're paperwork people and you know
I'm a realtor so I have it from the Real
Estate Commission it's the same thing
turn in your paperwork do it
thoroughly uh get your cus get it done
on time they're very big on on time and
pay your fees that's the most important
thing they're paperwork people they just
um uh if and if they give a license and
it actually turns out to be somebody who
really does harm the public it's no skin
off their nose they wasn't part of their
job so you know they're just really not
needed and I think there's actually a
negative part to having the State
Licensing which is it gives a false
sense of security to the public that
well they the state gave them license so
you know they must be okay no you as a
consumer we all know as consumers we
have to do our own vetting your number
one source is word of mouth and
reputation when I moved here and got my
dog I uh you know I asked my neighbor
where do you go for vet services and
that's who I use until I wasn't happy
with them then I found somebody else so
Word of Mouth reputation your second
best source is certification from the uh
private you know the Professional
Organization ation um long as they're in
good standing and you have to do it
every 3 years anyway and the third
Source we have right now is the
licensing and I just don't think they
add anything to the process so we should
eliminate them save everybody time and
money and that's it that's why I support
the
Bill thank you are there any questions
from the
committee don't see thank very
good is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill
1233 all right seeing that I will close
the public hearing I I do want make a
comment though we don't we have no one
from oplc to um speak to their agreement
to do
this BR laus yeah they were involved in
the subcommittee where we came up with
the amendment and they were okay with it
at the time
okay thank
you if we I close the public hearing if
we wish to discuss it we should go into
executive
session I'm just curious um if this bill
is exactly the same as the bill that the
Senate killed uh what makes us think
it's going to go anywhere represent laus
yeah I mean I I spoke with uh
representative Kelly you know after the
fact unfortunately but yeah her I mean
her mother had a massive stroke and she
was spending all her time in the
hospital and so no one showed up to
introduce the bill to Senate Eda and
they ited at 5 to Zer by default and
then that passed by a Voice vote in the
full Senate and um I'm I'm expecting
that with somebody explaining the bill
to them they might do something
different at least I hope so okay
representative gold I was asking you if
we were in executive session are you you
willing to entertain a motion yes I move
ought to pass on House Bill 128 1233 and
I'll second all right do you wish to
speak to your motion thank you madam
chair uh I think I may have uh mentioned
this last year but I want to share that
several years ago I had a very sick
rabbit I was losing rabbits a lot of
rabbits they were dying and I went to a
very expensive exotic um pet vet and he
couldn't figure out he was pretty sure
it was poisoning of some sort he wanted
to do tests at several hundred dollar
per test and you had to test for one
chemical at a time my chiropractor who
was formerly the state examiner of all
chiropractors could not legally treat me
do any work for me but he could do me a
favor as a friend and so he's passed on
I'm not uh risking any problems for him
he agreed to see my rabbit after hours
for no pay and the vet knew it was
happening and was very interested in the
results and we determined that my
rabbits were being poisoned by my garden
hoses that were made in China with very
toxic chemicals inside that never would
have been tested by the vet so I highly
support this bill there's a place for
all services for our animals and we need
to take care of them thank
you represent blackis thank you um so
right right now as far as I know there
aren't veterinarians that are doing
Chiropractic for Animals there may be a
few I don't know but it is going on
there are people doing Chiropractic on
animals basically under the table it was
and still is maybe a little gray area as
to whether they have to be currently
they should be licensed as vets or not
it's unclear there I know there are
people doing it and they're not
advertising because their status is
unclear what this would do is um you
know at least require that they be uh
certified by a nationally recognized
certification organization which exists
is I was interested to find out and and
so you know people will have some
assurance that they've had some training
and there's some uh review but you know
requiring they actually become
full-blown vets is excessive for this
and the problem is even if vets did this
um I guess trying to get an appointment
with a vet can take a very long time and
it's quite expensive so that's my
argument that's testimony we got anyway
represent man thank you madam chair so
this is nationally accredited so it can
be transferable from one state to
another kind of so this is a national
accreditation
correct laus that's my understanding
maybe there's someone here who is more
uh knows more about it but but that
wouldn't really affect this bill I mean
it is a National Organization and the uh
this bill would allow oplc under 541a
rulemaking to determine the the
organization or organizations that would
meet the New Hampshire
requirement okay any other
representative
Schmid than you madam chair one of the
other things we heard last year was that
people were having to go to a vet to get
a referral to a CH animal chiropractor
they would have to wait sometimes weeks
to get the appointment with the vet just
to get a
referral so it it's a complete catch22
situation that made no sense and the
committee recognized that representative
Kelly was bringing a simple concept to
solve the problem so it sailed through
the house and just unfortunate that
nobody there but if the Senate if you
don't have somebody to open the bill in
the Senate they don't like that I don't
blame
them
represent geart thank you I'm just
curious so if the bill goes through and
somebody's massaging a squirrel without
the nationally accredited requirement
are they going to be locked up or what
is the penalties
for that's a very good
question I don't believe that
this addresses the issue of unauthorized
animal Chiropractic it just says that if
you are Ally
certified um you don't need a Veterinary
license um but representative laus I I
don't know the exact penalty but I guess
what's happened in the past there's when
it's come to light that people are doing
this we heard testimony that some people
had
gotten what could be called threatening
letters from the veterinary board saying
they shouldn't be doing it and so you
know arguably if somebody was doing this
without the certification whatever the
penalty was for for practicing
Veterinary uh medicine without a license
maybe could apply maybe
okay I hope you're not running an
authorized animal chiropractic clinic in
your backyard represent of Gard that
would that would stretch the system
representative Brown uh maybe I should
have asked this uh outside of exec
session so it it it says on line five uh
line four and five the executive
director in accordance with rules
adopted etc etc in consultation with
Board of veterinary medicine and
Chiropractic examiners which if HB 1676
passes uh Board of veterinary medicine
will be gone in what year I can't 2025
and so it's just a thought that
somewhere along the line that will have
to be corrected or or if that were to
pass 1676 were to pass and we decided to
make a change to any of the boards
mentioned in it there would be a
sweeping revision of all sorts of
statutes
reir and let's
not ask for trouble in
advance anyone
else all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass by representative gold
will clerk can call the role yes
representa luus yes representative
Bailey yes representative Gart yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes the clerk votes yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative Mii py yes and
the chair yes the um vote is for 14
to0 motion passes excellent the motion
passes does
anyone object to
consent okay we'll try
again okay
and close the executive session and to
give representative gou time to write
her committee report and uh we will
resume at 11
Co
good morning welcome back to
Edna I'm opening the hearing on House
Bill 1272 and call Representative
power
thank you Madame chair and honorable
colleagues as the prime sponsor I
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
to you today house spill
1272 for the record I am representative
Diane power I represent the towns of
Brookline Mason and Greenville in
Hillsboro County District 36 to begin
this is a simple straightforward Common
Sense Bill the purpose of this bill is
to streamline the reciprocity licensing
process in New Hampshire current statute
RSA
3310-a license
reciprocity authorizes oplc to issue New
Hampshire licenses to outof State
applicants licensed in another state
provided that that the other State's
licensing requirements are substantially
similar to those in New Hampshire the
issue that this bill seeks to address is
this necessitating that another State's
licensing requirements be substantially
similar to those in New Hampshire
undoubtedly places additional
unnecessary burdens on both the outof
state licensed professional as well as
oplc this bill simply eliminates the
quote substantially similar unquote
language in the current
statute and this is shown in lines 6
through n of the bill text this simple
change has a number of benefits first
this bill eliminates unnecessary
barriers that are needlessly perpetuated
by the quote substantially similar
unquote language and current statute to
be clear licensed professionals that
have already successfully completed
their education obtained the required
training hours passed a professional
licensing exam and satisfied all of the
standards and requirements of a of a
State Licensing body any additional
unnecessary red T tape makes no sense
licensed professionals do not lose their
job skills and work rated experience
once they cross state lines second this
bill Cuts this unnecessary red T tape
and it simplifies the process for
everyone involved any additional
standards and or requirements imposed by
the substantially similar language in
the current statute undoubtedly creates
a burdensome administrative process for
both a oplc and the out ofate licensed
professionals this costs both time and
money by simplifying the current process
the verification procedure for oplc is
greatly streamlined currently oplc must
maintain up-to-date information on the
licensing requirements of other
jurisdictions which can change
frequently compounding this challenge
OPC must also maintain a history of
licensing requirements and other dist
jurisdictions for the many licensed
professions in order to compare the
actual requirements that were in place
when the outof state applicant earned
their occupational license importantly
by simplifying the current process
licensed professionals new to our state
can more easily and more quickly obtain
a New Hampshire license and thus
beginning begin to be able to work
sooner than later in our state providing
Professional Services third this bill
eliminates unnecessary barriers to
Interstate Mobility which in turn it
benefits workers employers and
consumers and this mostly affects women
as well as people of color that are
coming from other states this bill also
supports Working Families and and it
helps to eliminate New Hampshire's
severe labor shortage by expanding our
labor force I would say this is a
win-win for everyone and finally by
eliminating unnecessary red tape for
licensed professionals this bill
supports the governor's initiative to
reform occupational Licensing in the
granite
state in
conclusion this bill applies only to
licensed profession
who hold active out ofate licenses in
good
standing however I do acknowledge that
our New Hampshire
laws in the areas of um real estate
residential electricians natur paaths
and land
surveys I I am willing to to work with
whomever to to
address those areas of Statute and how
this particular bill um might affect
affect those those licensed professions
the bill requires oplc to issue licenses
to outof State licensed professionals
without any additional requirements this
bill eliminates the administrative
burden for oplc to track current as well
as historic licensing requirements
across all jurisdictions and all
licensed professions this bill enables
licensed professionals to be able to
quickly work in our state without any
additional burdensome red tape or
unnecessary delay the bill supports the
governor's occupational licensing reform
initiatives and most importantly this
bill strengthens and expands our economy
which in support which in turn supports
our hardworking Granite State families
Madam chair that concludes my bill
introduction and I'm happy to take any
questions if you permit
thank
you are there
questions yes thank you representative
Schmidt I was checking everybody to make
sure who would be there thank you for
your
help representative
Brown thank you madam
chair
uh here we go thank you for taking my
question so philosophically I agree with
streamlining the process does this does
this
mean that New
Hampshire's licensing requirements
should be only equivalent to every other
states for any license and that we
shouldn't consider making them more
restrictive for reasons that our
own uh citizens might
want thank you for the question
representative so to be clear the
purpose of licensing is to establish
minimum standards it's it's not to
establish unreasonably like high
standards which creates
barriers for entry for people you know
to enter the workforce in New Hampshire
and I would also reiterate you know
carefully consider and contemplate that
this bill applies to people licensed
professional who hold a
current license in good
standing
so that that would be and it makes no it
makes no sense to me we all travel out
of the state of New Hampshire to other
states and you know we engage in I guess
you
know I guess Commerce if you will and at
times interact with other licensed
professionals we we we don't like if we
went on vacation to another state we're
we're not concerned about the licensing
and the
requirements and education of say a
cosmetologist to style our
hair okay thank
you
ba it's not just related to this but in
general when somebody
licensed in another state comes to work
here do they announce themselves in some
way or tell oplc oh by the way I'll be
working there thank you for the question
representative the the process is is
that when somebody from out of state
that's a licensed professional wishes to
you know practice provide services in
the state of New Hampshire they they
need to be licens by the state of New
Hampshire and so there's an application
process which they you know apply apply
for the New Hampshire license and that
that goes through
oplc and with current statute that would
oplc Works closely with boards and
commissions in order to make that
determination under the current
law I knew it would be something like
that thank you
representa thank you um representative
power do you have a list by state as
compared to New Hampshire for the
licenses that are less as stringent than
ours and more an
equivalent um thank you for the question
representative I do not have that list
with me here right in on the witness
stand um that would be a a daunting task
there like I said there's number of we
have to deal with the jurisdictions
which are the 50 states the District of
Colombia and the five inhabited
territories of the United States so
those are the jurisdictions and
then you you're you're talking about
licensed professions that that would be
a huge resar research project I'm sure
oplc has that that that information but
I don't have it printed out right here
I'm sorry a followup follow up I hope
you don't feel like you're on a witness
stand because this is not a court okay
second of all I'm sure that data is
available and if you don't have it I'll
ask someone else thank you yes
representative Fitzpatrick uh thank you
madam chair uh in theory I'm in favor of
this concept has there been any thought
to
retrocity in that
uh we will recognize in other states
licensing if they recognize
ours in other words uh our someone
someone from our state moving to moving
to another one I thank you for the
question representative it I believe and
it's my understanding that there are
licensed compacts with with other
states
um I can't really speak in particular to
to that I'm sure there are some expert
Witnesses behind me that that can answer
that question more um
completely
follow U it's
just you understand what I was asking in
other words we will recognize your
State's license people from your state
moving into ours if you will recognize
people from our State moving in new y
That's I I I understand um what you're
oh I I thank you representative I I
understand what you're saying but I to
me that that that's not a proper
criteria
um well that's my opinion but thank you
yeah
okay
brusa thank you um I was just thinking
last year we at put this Statute in
substantially subst substantially
similar because of the questions that we
had concerning barriers to entry so what
information do you have that leads you
to believe that this is not working
now so thank you for the question
representative I appreciate that it's if
you when you consider the the concept of
of Occupational licensing to reiterate
the purposes to establish minimum
standards and furthermore we can all
agree that we don't want to license um
you know license people that don't have
licenses this bill clearly pertains to
those that
hold a professional license from another
jurisdiction and that goes to the the
minimum standard
so with regards to to the purpose of
Licensing and what I can say is
that there are 40% 40% of the states
have moved to some form of universal
licensing the you know the first state
was Arizona in 2019 and now here in
2024 there are 20 of the 50 states that
have moved to to Universal licensing
if it wasn't a good thing then we would
not see that that shift it streamlines
the process it streamline lines the
process for licensing and and it helps
the professionals did that answer the
question actually no but we'll try it
again
the the next speaker will be executive
director courn who will be describing
how we implemented the substantially
similar requirement because I think that
will answer some questions both from the
committee and from other people in the
audience okay representative Brown and
then
Shu okay thank you representative
Shu thank you madam chair um I'm a
little uncomfortable with the language
another
jurisdiction you're saying that's other
US states and territories but that
doesn't actually limit U could be
European it could be African it could
be thank you for the question
representative I am H I was having a
little bit of trouble hearing you but if
I understood the
question your concern is with regards to
the to the term jurisdictions so I've
been in front of this committee um four
times previously with occupational
licensing reform bills and in fact one
of my
bills that it focused specifically on
cosmetology a Aesthetics and barbering
out ofate lure and it was exactly the
same as this bill in front of you but it
just focused on that one profession and
as in the hearing I did get feedback
from
oplc um with regards to the the use of
that word jurisdiction so I I feel very
comfortable including that in this
language okay thank you
representative Smith and then manra py
thank you madam chairman um good even
good afternoon morning whatever uh I
have a question he brought it up um if
you have a driver's license from Vermont
and you move to New Hampshire you have
to get a new driver's
license it do will this bill cover
something like that no driver's licenses
are not considered professional licenses
okay I also have another question if
that's okay uh I moved from Missouri to
New Hampshire a few years ago I had a
real estate license in uh Missouri a
broker's license I could not or I I
would have had to take classes again in
order to get a New Hampshire one same
thing with a teaching
certificate um I had to take classes
will this cover that Gap thank you for
the question representative as I stated
in my bill introduction I do acknowledge
that there are some licensed professions
that we need perhaps to consider more
and real
estate was was one of them so I would be
um willing to work with whomever
oplc um Etc to to address that if if
needed and um work on an amendment yes
representative Smith you may not have
been aware but New Hampshire has some
really bizarre land ownership laws and
the deeds and anyone coming in as a real
estate lensey would need to get training
and pass a test on New Hampshire
specific laws but other than that your
your your license is good for the
general knowledge but not the New
Hampshire specific
knowledge man py thank you madam chair
thank you representative for U taking my
question do you have any idea how many
licensing Fields this is going to have
an effect licensed professionals that
will this bill would change thank you
representative that that's a very good
question so
um to be clear this bill would only
affect
professions that are Li that are
licensed for so for example if there's a
profession that's a person that's coming
from another state and they don't have a
license but New Hampshire licenses that
profession this bill would not apply to
them and they would not be able to
obtain a New Hampshire license because
they didn't hold a current active valid
license from out of state and I
mentioned that rep that director
Courtney would be the best person to
answer the numbers questions because
she's got that data uh Madam chair yes
do you anticipate this going to
subcommittee and if so I was going to
say that the exceptions could maybe be
brought up and worked out there that it
is in fact going to go to subcommittee
surprise it is your
subcommittee so uh yes and I think
specific exemptions would be best
covered in in subcommittee all right
thank you all right any other questions
representative gold I have a follow-up
question on uh International licensing
but is that best left for um I think so
yes anyone else all right thank you very
much representative power thank you
director
Courtney
yeah good morning Madam chair members of
the committee uh Lindsey Corney
executive director
oplc um so just want to make clear that
the office is not taking an official op
position on this bill um did want to
offer a few comments and I'm of course
happy to answer any of your questions uh
regarding what we're doing now or
regarding how we would implement this
bill as proposed
so I think um I think it's important to
understand that the whole concept
regarding portability or an endorsement
is based on an understanding that uh
you're comparing Apples to
Apples um and when we start talking
about um removing requirement that we do
that comparison you could get into a
situation where you're comparing apples
to oranges in the sense that um the
license that is coming or the person
with the license coming from another
state doesn't actually
have uh the same license because they
didn't undertake the same education
training and experience and I think
you've recognized or representative
power has recognized that there are
several notable exceptions to this
naturopath being one of them in our
state you need a doctorate level degree
you're authorized to prescribe
controlled drugs in other states you
need a two-e webinar and so under this
proposed language somebody with a two-e
webinar could come in in get licensed
and prescribe control drugs that's
really not consistent with the concept
of
portability the other issue that I think
is less obvious um relates to the fact
that many states license the same
professions but call them different
things we see that in the context of the
mental health field in particular um
they're very much in favor of the
acronyms and I struggle to keep up with
the different
acronyms um but essentially you know for
example in the field of alcohol and drug
use counseling um
many states refer to what our license
type is as a licensed alcohol and drug
use counselor as something completely
different and you're not going to know
whether or not that person coming in um
should be licensed under this language
unless you do the comparison you're
going to have to do the comparison in
certain in certain Fields so I we fully
support uh portability um absolutely and
I would say that the legislative
initiatives that um were spearheaded and
supported by Governor snoooo last
session um regarding HP 594 in
particular um we are we have made great
inroads in terms in terms of
streamlining the process uh for those
professions that we've implemented um
RSA 310 colon 17 for um we're down to 24
business you know 24 hours or less in
terms of issuing a license it's pretty
streamlined um but I would just say that
I think that the you know the committee
should probably consider the purpose of
portability it does it will always
require some sort of analysis um and
some sort of comparison between other
states with that I'd be happy to answer
any questions okay representative leus
and then man py thank you um so I guess
the the question is you said there
there's going to have to be some
comparison so the the question is is um
in or you know to do as much in the way
of reciprocity as possible but to deal
with the situations you
raised um are there changes to stat
current statute that would would help
that along but still allow the
comparisons that you feel are
necessary I think the legislature really
struck the right balance last session
because if you recall that the um with a
substantially similar language because
if you look in 332g which is the
predecessor to RSA
33017 it spoke of substantial
equivalency and the challenge with that
is it was frequently interpreted as
actual equivalency um to the point where
people who are coming from other states
uh that didn't require you know that you
know a photo to be submitted with the
application were getting denied I mean
that's just totally absurd um so by
changing the language to substantially
similar um I think that that really did
strike the right balance because it it
contemplates that the core
requirements um have to be satisfied and
if you look at the interim rules that
the office has adopted as well as the
rules that we just filed you will see
that it we are comparing Apples to
Apples but we are allowing folks to come
in from other jurisdictions that have
different requirements but that are
similar that we feel are meeting um both
the education and experience that is
necess
um in order to be minimally competent in
our state and the other thing to
understand too is that every state has
you know their own authority regarding
scope of practice so it could be that
you know as I brought up with
naturopaths the webinar is perfectly
fine for whatever naturopaths do in that
particular State because they have a
different scope of practice and so when
we're looking at competency we're
looking at competency for our scope of
practice and modifying scope of practice
in the future to address minimum
competency could have a different impact
on Workforce and and and access to care
so to answer your short question or your
question I think that really last year
we struck the right
balance um with a substantially similar
language all right thank you represent
man py thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question how many licensed
Fields would this
affect depending
on how sweeping it can be sure we have
over 200 license types um that's not
including temporary license types when
you factor those in I mean there's
there's a lot more um but over 200
license
types followup thank you and this also
impacts the public safety service to our
Granite Staters correct all
licensing certainly because the purpose
of Licensing is to protect the public so
you need to ensure as representative
power mentioned that you're establishing
minimum qualifications it's not to
promote the professionals to protect the
public through minimum qualifications
thank you represent
Goldie thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my
question
so the language we worked out last year
in here is working currently the way
you're doing things if we went to
try and change the language like that is
here we would have to start going
through individual licensing to see who
would fit better to compare the Apples
to Apples and the versus apples to
oranges whereas if we leave a
standardized language for all licensing
would make it much easier on you making
sure
that they're
considerably the same when they're
coming from State to state for a licing
here in
Hampshire yeah so I'll give you an
example
um there are in barbering for example a
lot of States actually New Hampshire is
ahead of the game right because we've
split up the lure requirements so we
have both a barber and a master Barber
requirement I think our
Barbers I don't want to misspeak but
it's it's somewhere in the 750 hours
range is what it's required and then we
have a master Barber course so a lot of
states only have one one barber license
but they actually have the requirement
their Education and Training is at our
Master Barber level so under this as
proposed certainly I could issue them a
barber license but that's not what they
were trained to do but I'm not going to
know that until I open up that states uh
statutes and rules to understand that
they were actually trained to be a
master Barber and we should be issuing
doing the master barber license so I
think either under this language or the
other language in order to really do you
know do the lcy Justice you have to look
at what the requirements are I don't
know if that answers your question
followup it does and so I I'm just
trying to get to that the language we
use currently for all licensing with
this is currently in statute
is more beneficial for encompassing all
licensing versus trying to figure out
where we should remove it from
yes and the other thing that I would say
is the current statute requires us to
consult with the
boards and well I don't think that you
know always has to be a statutory
requirement for my own practice I'm
obviously not always going to be here I
think there's a benefit to having that
in statute and I'll bring up an example
um marriage and family therapists if you
just look at um so in our state they are
required to have 3,000 hours of
postgraduate experience experience in
their rules they have to have a th hours
of direct client contact so if you just
look at our
statute um and we you do an analysis
you're like okay well the statute only
speaks to um experience the postgraduate
experience it doesn't speak to the type
of experience so um if you just look at
our statute you may say that you know
maybe like two 2500 is sufficiently um
comparable but the problem is a lot of
states don't impose postgraduate
experience they impose requirements only
for direct patient
contact and I found that working with
the board was really helpful to
understand you know how many hours of
direct patient contact are equal to um
total experience because if we didn't
have if I didn't have that expertise I
would we would have excluded like 30
States um which is something we don't
want to do um and so I think having that
requirement in statute is also really
helpful and it Fosters that
collaborative working
relationship thank you repr gold and
then
lus thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my
question and I know this is going to
subcommittee and we can discuss things
in more detail then but my question is
is there currently any path for you your
office and the boards to look at
International rep I'm not going to be
able to say that word rep Pro yeah yes
yeah yeah that word Yes actually in the
rules that we just filed um we have a
hearing on March 7th uh hopefully we'll
make it in time for the April jail card
date but in the rules we just filed we
contemplate a scenario for um
International or foreign trained um
lenses and what we've proposed is that
they are required to go to a recognized
third party to have their credential and
their education evaluated it's a process
that we already use in other license
types Physical Therapy Board of Medicine
and essentially that third party says
yes this is what they got in Sweden this
is what is required in Sweden this you
know and this is how this compares to
our requirements and then we would be
able to do the analysis of whether or
not um you know that jurisic
jurisdiction has sufficiently similar
requirements um so we are proposing that
you know obviously that's in the initial
draft I don't know what what will happen
but follow so if that passes as I read
through this I didn't see anything that
that defined the other jurisdictions as
having to be cont the United States
would that also make this apply to
International rules as you develop them
I think it's open to interpretation as
to what the term jurisdiction
means um and we've taken the position in
our our filing our rules filing that
jurisdiction is anywhere it's not
limited to a US jurisdiction I don't
know that that was the intent um that's
what we've just the plain language
jurisdiction is
jurisdiction represent leus and then
groer thank you um yeah I understand
your concern about just uh plane
removing the substantially similar
because you might need to do some
analysis
um but my concern and the reason I I'm
interested in this is that and maybe you
can help me with this is that
substantially similar to me is a very
kind of vague not well- defined term and
while I might think that your views on
it currently might be reasonable you
know as you said you're not going to be
there in the future so is there anything
that puts boundaries or real meaning on
what substantially similar means and
would provide you know guidance or
boundaries to how someone else might
interpret it in the
future on the actual phrase
substantially similar no um I would say
that our rules have addressed what we
think is substantially
similar what what um you know if you
look at some of the audit report from
clear the Council of leg uh Council on
licensing enforcement and regulation you
know they've always suggested like the
70% Mark which is what I say to boards
um you know look at the 70% Mark the
other thing that um we're looking at and
some boards have um wanted to
incorporate is okay so let's say the
state has an a requirement of a th000
hours we have 2,000 but this person has
been practicing for 30 years I mean is
there a mechanism for us to say that
experience should count toward that
requirement we've interpreted the
statute as allowing for that I'm not
sure sure that it's explicit so if
you're considering a statutory change
that might be something um to take into
consideration followup follow up um yeah
I mean that's a concern I've had with
substantially simar all along and you
know if you have some language that
might replace substantially similar
rather than completely removing it but
might you think allow you to do a better
job um not right now necessarily but
being interest in SE it thank you yes
representative
gr so last year we dealt with this issue
because we felt that there was
some
unmeasurable uh conditions to lenser
such as essay exams essay we remove
those so we have tried to which should
help with the definition of
substantially similar can you comment on
that
please yes so most boards had an
endorsement process um but I would say
it was not true endorsement so I'll give
you an example um one of our license
types um in order to you know to get a
license initially you have to do an exam
you have to have a supervisor you have
to have an internship you have to have
somebody sign off so the endorsement
process was you have to do all of that
and show us proof that you are licensed
in another state so that's not true
endorsement endorsement is show us you
have a license in another state and we
issue a license so 594 really addressed
that issue it got rid of those types of
processes where somebody has to do
everything plus um show that you know
that they're licensed in another state
and I think it's been very successful um
for the license types that we've
implemented on day one um of
implementation of our interim rules we
were able to issue 70 physician licenses
who had just been hanging out forever
because they were waiting on letters of
reference um and you know that to me is
is silly um but in any event I it was
very I mean it's been very effective you
don't need letters of reference anymore
we just need to know that you're licens
and good standing in another
state okay B
garard thank you madam
chair so this addresses an issue that
was raised brought to my attention by a
tattoo shop owner and I just want to
know if this would help fix the
situation
where unlike other licenses where
there's a standard test um RSA 314 A3
the apprenticeship for tattooist last
sentence A person shall remain an
apprentice for at least one year and
until the supervising ly attests that
The Apprentice is qualified to become
licensed yeah so it's my understanding
that there are certain tattooists that
are basically holding the apprentice's
license Ransom until until a certain sum
is paid would this help alleviate that
uh this
bill I don't know more than anything
else that I'm aware of that issue there
is a problem with with the um statute
generally I think um and we have taken
enforcement actions when it has come to
our attention regarding that um I would
say that body art was included in the
interm rules specifically because we
require an apprentice ship of a c in New
Hampshire even if you're licensed in
another state which is crazy um and so
we were able to address the overall
issue of portability through with body
art through the
594 um many states do not license party
artists at the personal level they only
um license the establishments and it's
actually done through local uh
Departments of Public Health and so
that's another issue comparing apples to
oranges you know you want to make sure
you're looking at those requirements um
but I would say that that that's a
separate Enforcement issue of somebody
basically um utilizing their position of
authority to um you know outside of what
they're supposed to be doing thank you
representative
Brown thank you madam chair uh thanks
for taking my question so if if I
interpret this
correctly if a person comes from a state
that has a lesser requir reement for a
license and and this passes they can
come here those that here are here in
the state still have a greater
requirement to get that same license yes
I would say the distinction is not
necessarily where they reside it's where
they're initially licensed so if they
don't have a license and they're going
through the yes correct okay and
followup if I might
and based on what I heard last week in
testimony there would it be your opinion
that there will be push back from those
that already have licenses on this Phil
representative Brown the people here to
testify on this bill are example of such
push back thank
you yes uh I have a simpler question
sure I know you have interim rules on
defining what is substantially similar
how many Prof for how many professions
have you issued those
rules I believe it's 13 I want to go
back and count but I believe it's 13 and
what we did is we prioritized the ones
that we thought would have the greatest
impact um that's why I picked body art
you know most people are like they don't
have a a a portability issue they they
absolutely do um and uh you know summon
healthare we also prioritized
electricians um and it pretty much lined
up with what their portability was
previously but we streamlined the
process okay thank you any other
questions all right thank you thank you
very much thank you for your
time all
right the uh
Realtors um Sarah
Holland thank you madam chair thank you
members of the committee my name is
Sarah Holland I am a real estate lensee
and a licensed real estate instructor um
and I am here on behalf of the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors as the
vice chair of their public policy
committee we do appreciate the sponsor
statement relative to real estate
licensing though we oppose um the bill
as written this is a consumer protection
issue we currently have a low barrier to
entry in the existing recognition
process where we Rec recognize that a
real estate professional in a different
state has gone through the basic
education and the national portion um to
prove that they um have that basic
knowledge what we're asking for in the
res recognition process is that they
share their knowledge of or get tested
on their knowledge of New Hampshire
specific laws so that looks like a 40
question exam where no education is
required they just have to know the
information
um a background check and a licensing
fee our neb neighboring states utilize
the same process because it just makes
sense um once you cross borders
Everything Changes um in regards to
Escrow accounts disclosure requirements
mandated um mandated disclosures
environmental regulations zoning laws
private Wells septics even the process
of submitting an offer and accepting an
offer can be very different across
borders I am licensed in both New
Hampshire and Vermont and previously
licensed in Massachusetts and
Connecticut and I am thankful that I had
to go through this recognition process
and take that basic knowledge um exam to
be able to
share that I knew what I was doing when
I crossed those
borders um as a licensed real estate
educator I can attest to relative to the
barrier to entry for
recognition our process is incredibly
fast in New Hampshire um the application
and the testing process is fast and it's
also it's often months faster than our
neighboring states um as As Told to me
by our students that are testing in
those areas okay so to summarize our
opposition to this bill this bill
provides benefit to prospective outof
State agents only it does not benefit
the consumer by requiring even the basic
knowledge of New Hampshire's rules and
regulations resulting in great legal and
financial exposure to those consumers
our current recognition process is
working it's efficient and effective and
as director Courtney has stated in
previous testimony on previous bills
that we have opposed um that New
Hampshire is not substantially similar
to any of our neighboring states I'm
happy to take it any questions thank you
represent
Schmid thank you madam chair you've
heard it's going to a subcommittee will
you be available for the subcommittee
happy to thank
you all right thank you for your
testimony Mr ranc
Court
good morning Madam chair my name is
Steven rord I'm a licensed electrician
in the state of New Hampshire and I'm
here to testify on behalf of House Bill
127 too we're passing around a handout
but
um we want to state that begin with we
we welcome reciprocity we actually have
reciprocity at over 21 states or
somewhere around that number right now
we've reached out long before this even
became an issue so we're all for trying
to get reciprocity but we think it
should be fair and balanced in order to
do it we oppose the bill as written and
um I can start as they passing that
around just we spent a lot of time in
the last couple of years with with OP
oplc bills um coming in and trying to
make sure that we're changing the laws
and fixing the rules so that everything
is objective and not
subjective and by taking this out you
kind of leave the entire bill as
subjective to the OPC and the executive
director at the time so objectivity is
something that we feel is important if
if we're going to continue to do that
through everything else in the rules and
oplc and all the other requirements why
aren't doing it
here um as far as our concerns the
executive director concerns not
specifically with one that we have now
but just in general that because this
position is an appointed position and
can be it will change over
time that person may have different
views and decide what similar
substantially equivalent is we don't
really want to have that roller coaster
I don't think back and forth to that we
we we should really work on trying to
just clarify substantially equivalent I
think the institutional knowledge as the
Director spoke is is with the boards is
huge some of these boards and people in
these boards have been around for years
and experienced a lot and that's
important for Public Safety as well in
the state which is why these boards were
originally formed way back for Public
Safety so we don't want to lose that and
that was the last SEC um comment as far
as the concern not losing that for
substantially equivalent um I think
that what would probably be best and I
apologize there taking a lot of notes as
testimony so they um is finding I think
what fix it all to be honest with you
just finding a minimum stand up is
substantially equivalent and it really
isn't that hard to
Define okay you pick a percentage
whatever that percentage is of whatever
your particular laws are right now and
you say Okay substantially equivalent
let's just say is
90% or if you don't have all the
paperwork and all the information if you
you know you can't produce your
schooling paperwork and and things like
that I've been doing this for 30 plus
years and uh not to give away a old but
I couldn't find my school paperwork
probably if somebody asked me to to
prove that so you pick a standard you
pick a percentage and then you adjust
that percentage based on OJT experience
how long they've been licensed now
defining those needs to be worked out
whether you say you know after five
years you only need 70% or after 10
years you need 60% because again that
work experience means something so you
could Define that fairly simply with
something to that effect something like
that um the other thing too is you could
solve this very easily by simply saying
after a minimum amount of time license
you can take a test and if you pass you
get it it eliminates all of this why do
we all had to pass a test to to get
licens in the state so it's a simple way
to fix it we have to go to another state
we don't have to test if they're not
reciprocating with us so you don't have
to worry about who determines
substantially equipment if they pass the
test right and say they've been licensed
for 2 to 5 years something like that so
there's many um you know this represents
over 54 to 60 boards I know it's changed
over time over 177,000 licenses this is
a huge impact and and I think it's
important that we try to find the right
fix for it and I think that keeping an
objective and defining substantially
equivalent is really what is going to
have the biggest impact thank you are
there questions representative lais
thank you um
I understand what you're getting at and
and you know it's having people take the
test if they're moving from one state to
the other may seem reasonable but if
it's reasonable for them if they've been
pract you know if they've been
practicing for 20 years and they have to
take the test to get the license here I
mean is it also reasonable to say that
people who are currently licensed need
to take the test again every 10 years or
whatever to maintain license I mean
would you support that as well well the
difference is they went through the most
of them probably obviously depends how
long they've been license went through
the requirements here in the state to
get it whereas we don't really know out
of state you know take an instance I
think Colorado has half the amount of
hours schooling wise that we have so I
mean that's important I mean you you'd
want to know that so I'm just offering
the licensing part as an option not just
the only one like that could be an
option all right thank you
thank thank you very much Mr
Anor U Michael Harrison with the
mechanical
licensing do you mind if Mr trumbley
joins
you okay thank
you
there thank you good
luck since these boards are uh
professions are intertwined I they
figured you'd be able to speak together
good uh morning uh Madame chair and
committee MERS my name is Bill Trombley
and I am the owner of Bill Trombley
Plumbing Heating in Manchester New
Hampshire and I'm here to uh
representing the gas uh Fitts
Association and we're opposed to this
language and this uh in the bill um one
of the things that kind of want to bring
out
with the trades the education is
different from state to state and some
of the other professional licenses maybe
in the uh the nursing and dental you
know they're going to college there's
some standards in there throughout the
national and plumbing um and gas fitting
um there is no real National Standard on
the training and on the education the
states and sometimes the the the the
cities get the pick to choose what
they're going to how they're going to
train their their
technicians um in New Hampshire our gas
license is kind of unique that is
something that a lot of uh States and
counties do not have a separate gas
license uh per se some they um sometimes
their Plumbing license will cover their
gas license and in a lot of states there
is no such thing is licensing there is
no Plumbing license there is no gas
license um New York there is no State pl
plumbing license there's City licenses
and stuff like that um so there's a lot
of states that there is no license and I
understand that this bill says it has to
have the license I uh I wasn't as uh as
thorough as as Mr anot was I didn't have
copies for everybody but just kind of
give you an example I handed out uh
minutes from the main plumbing board um
that I applied for my main Plumbing
license now I've been licensed in the
State of New Hampshire since
1985 as an apprentice I had my master
plumbing license by 1990 I've installed
thousands of uh uh Plumbing in houses
and gas furnaces I've been in the
business for a ton of years okay and um
done been on many code boards and
everything else like that and I was
denied my main Plumbing license because
their code is different from our code so
they have in their language similar
equivalent and they did not they did not
believe that New Hampshire laws and New
Hampshire training was similar
equivalent to their training in laws
over here in New Hampshire we go to
school as a plumber for four years Maine
it's two years Massachusetts it's five
years Vermont it's four years it's all
over the place okay so um Maine uses a
different code than New Hampshire
Massachusetts uses a different code than
New Hampshire theart is on the same code
that we are they might be on a different
year but they're on the same code so
right now the way it's working is um if
you have a uh license or I should say
the way it was working if you have a
license they're testing so you come in
you have a journeyman's license from
Massachusetts they take a test that's in
with the codes of uh New Hampshire and
also it covers the laws of New Hampshire
also if I go to new to uh Massachusetts
I have to do the same thing I have to
take a test and obviously now you can
see if I go to if I want my main license
I will have to take a main test in order
to pass their test even though I went to
a four-year Apprentice program and there
is a 2-year Apprentice program okay so
what could happen especially on the
plumbing side um you you know people
from New Hampshire will go to could go
to Maine get their license in 2 years
and then if you don't have that testing
equipment testing um um scenario they
can come to New Hampshire and get their
license in two years where maybe
somebody that lives on the west uh side
or north um New Hampshire is not going
to travel all the way over to Maine to
get their license in two years so right
now the way it's working for the
plumbing license and the gas license
where they show up they're showing that
they they have the equivalent education
they get to take the tests and if they
pass the test they get the license so
representative to answer your your your
question to Steve was what happens if in
10 years you get your license should you
take a test well once you get your
license you have to go to continuing
education so we're going to continu
education every every year and if that
person gets their license in New
Hampshire they're going to have to go to
continuing education that New Hampshire
uh approves anyways so the reciprocity
reciprocity you all know you know New
Hampshire's given something and the
other state is given something that's
not the case in plumbing or gas they
there I can't go to New Hampshire and
get the and get my license and I mean I
can't go to massachusett and get my
license just because I have a license in
New Hampshire it will never happen if
this
passes I'm not quite sure why plumbers
are a little stubborn they think they
every state believes that their Plumbing
does something special um but you know
um they the reciprocity has been very
very very tough to get with the new New
England states so um with the gasfitters
association we believe that there should
should be some type of testing mechanism
that is involved in there so I think
thank you for your time Mr
Harrington good morning uh thank you to
the committee Madam chairman I'll keep
it brief I have a statement here on
behalf of the mechanical licensing board
my name is Michael Harrison I'm a member
of that board I'm a master plumber in
New Hampshire as well as a certified gas
fitter uh I'm also a master plumber in
Massachusetts and um I'm the sponsor for
the apprenticeship program at Oliver
mechanical in Manchester New
Hampshire um so I believe that I'm
well placed um to answer any questions
that you may
have um allowing outof state licenses to
reciprocate in New Hampshire without
them having to be substantially similar
to ours undermines Public
Safety as an example there are many
states across the country that do not
take the responsibility of providing
heating and plumbing services to their
citizens as seriously as
ours one being our neighbors in Vermont
who do not require on the job training
prior to the issuance of licensure to
install gas fired
appliances instead they rely on the
legal system to police this after the
public has been
harmed the mechanical licensing and
safety board asks that New Hampshire not
jeopardize the citizens of New Hampshire
by allowing professional licensure to be
eroded by the Legislative process thank
you for your time and
consideration thank you very much are
there any
questions could I please have a copy of
what you were reading from if possible
for our files
were you reading from oh you're reading
from your phone I apologize okay
apologies if you could email it your
phone I can't yeah we'll we'll just take
a copy thank you representment yeah okay
thank you any other
questions I would would one of you one
or both of you be willing to work with
the subcommittee because I think it's a
a real concern yes of course thank
you all right Drew
Klein Madame chairman members of the
committee I'm Drew Klein for president
of the Josiah barlet Center for Public
Policy thank you for having me I did
submit written comment so I won't take
up a lot of time you can read what we
submitted but I just wanted to point out
that in the last decade so from 2013 to
2023 21
states
have switched to Universal licensed
reciprocity laws they've adopted these
laws uh so New Hampshire when it adopted
its law last year was not at the
Vanguard of some movement we were way
behind um this movement to recognize out
ofate
licenses although were the first state
in New England England to do
it but one thing that you'll notice in
these laws is that out of those 21 only
nine have that requirement that we have
for substantially
similar license requirements among
states and in fact the experience has
been we've seen no States go backwards
and add that language in this last
decade but we have seen states that
initially had it go back and take it
out Missouri and uh New Mexico I think
were the two states who did that and the
they did it because they were seeing
that it was causing problems
um we do not have evidence from research
that
having really stringent occupational
Licensing Laws um and you know when we
have these variations in state laws that
that creates big variations in public
safety Public Health Health protections
that's just not the case based on
studies we've been able to see of these
laws but what we have seen is Big
variations in economic growth access and
employment so you see
substantial depressing effects on
employment from occupational Licensing
Laws that are that are strict New
Hampshire has a a pretty ser ious labor
shortage one of the reasons for passing
the law last year was to help with that
labor shortage striking this language to
do that I'd like to address some of the
comments that have been said before
really quickly it is in fact not easy as
it was suggested earlier to Simply
defined substantially similar I'll give
you a couple of examples cosmetology New
Hampshire is way out of line with the
national Norm on cosmetology uh training
hours we require 1,500 hours of
cosmetology
training uh the national the beauty
Association nationally doesn't recommend
that many hours Massachusetts requires
only a thousand hours so if you were to
imagine that you can concoct some
percentage 90% was suggested of hours of
training or hours of apprenticeships
well under that
standard no cosmetologist licensed in
Massachusetts could but could get a
license in New Hampshire under
reciprocity laws cuz their hours of
training are 33% lower than ours
barbering is another example uh New
Hampshire requires I think 800 hours of
training for
Barbers New York State requires 291
hours those are not substantially
similar if you were to apply some you
know uh percentage metric that might
sound good but no one here I I think
would suggest that uh Ryan CEST is
getting bad haircuts in New York City
because their Barbers only have fewer
than 300 hours of training so it's not
as easy as it would seem to come up with
a substantially similar test if you were
to start to try to base it on
percentages and
numbers it is in fact quite um
subjective the way we have it in law now
we happen to have a really fabulous
director of
oplc uh and I mean that seriously um who
does great work trying to figure all
this stuff
out but you can't rely on that forever
right and so it is pretty subjective the
problem with trying to make it more
objective is then you get into these
metrics that don't necessarily match up
so if we have a 33% difference in hours
of training in the classroom how do you
decide what is substantially similar to
that if you have different hours of
apprenticeships or on the job training
it gets very complicated very quickly
which is why most of the states that
have gone to Universal Licensing Laws in
the last decade don't have this language
in the laws and a couple of them that
did have pulled it back because it
actually
is not they have found really doing a
great job to protect public health and
safety but it is fing employment and
causing Mobility problems for their
states so I will leave it at that and
happy to answer any questions thank you
representative lus and then groa thank
you um so I mean a number of issues have
been raised around uh removing
substantially similar some of them are
around what are the licensing
differences in licensing requirements
but others that have been raised are
differences in the scope of practice
between you know what somebody with some
title can do a New Hampshire versus or
license can do New Hampshire versus
another state what I'm wondering is the
states have done this more you know they
don't have the language substantially
similar what do they do and how do they
deal with that those sorts of issues
yeah I mean I I haven't gotten down into
the language of the laws in every one of
those 21 states so I don't know that I
could speak um broadly on that but
obviously you have to address the scope
of practice right I mean that's just
something that um has to be addressed in
the law maybe there's a way to look at
it and look at what the other states
have done to
to um to address that that issue I mean
because that that is a legit issue and
then obviously with the um the real
estate is a great example if there are
specific laws that we have that um are
very different for New Hampshire so for
just to give another example right
barbering is barbering it doesn't matter
if you're cutting somebody's hair in
California Florida or New York um that's
different than real estate because the
the actual laws about land use and
everything so you can see a couple of
things where you might want to carve out
a profession um uh the law for example
right um that would be another one where
you might say okay that one will have
something but for most um occupations
you
know the training what we found in
looking at the training requirements is
you will occasionally find pretty big
gaps like the hours gaps or um on the
job training gaps but what we've seen in
the last couple of decades is states are
kind of coming together organically into
a lot
more um a lot closer training
requirements we're not there yet so and
that's part of the problem with the
substantially similar language it takes
time for these things to happen but for
basic professions that are um the same
from state to state to state you're
starting to see that they are kind of
gravitating towards you know sort of a a
ballpark of Fairly widely accepted
standards follow up follow up okay so on
the you know have these states just
playing you know remov substantially
similar what you said do they have it
just if you have a license that's more
or less the covers the same area in
another state that you automatically get
a license in their state so it's just
straight kind of re procy is the wrong
word it's licensed by endorsement
because well correct you know what do
they have any other caveats requirements
or or whatever again I'd have to I
wouldn't want to answer that question
without going through every single state
law but um to the suggestion that the a
good path would be reciprocity which
would really mean we only Grant a
license from a state if that state
grants a license in New Hampshire that
would actually be going backwards for
New Hampshire that would be um
economically very negative right so
right now we're saying if you have a
license in another state you can come
here Vis long substantially St we do not
want to go backwards and say um wait a
minute you have to recognize a New
Hampshire license too that would
actually make it harder for us to
recruit employees into New Hampshire so
we wouldn't want to go that way thank
you thank you in your testimony to us
you said that there is um data that will
demonstrate that Licensing in New
Hampshire or
they've removed this has expanded job
opportunities where is where is that
data I would be happy to send you reams
of academic info showing that um please
do yeah be happy to do that Josiah
Bartlet Center for Public Policy jet.org
we have some of that stuff on our
website you have a gentleman here in the
room whose organization has um done some
of the best work uh in the country on
looking at those laws and and the
effects of them and they actually have
to answer a previous question you had
for a previous caller
um we do have PR previous caller
previous guest uh we do have lists of um
state requirements uh it's not for all
200 occupations but for a lot of them
you can actually see what each state
requires hours um tests that kind of
thing so we love to see that yep okay
thank you are there other questions
representative Schmidt and then gold
thank you mam Cher can you provide us a
list of the 21 states you referenced
earlier absolutely I'll send you a link
to that it was done by um a thing tank
in Washington called The archbridge
Institute they looked back at that I can
get you that study thank you represent
gold thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question recently when I
was doing some research for another
bill excuse
me there was a report done about a dozen
years ago a national
report sorry I get a tickle right it
always happens when you're starting to
talk doesn't it Madam chair I'll have to
pass
okay represent goalie and then Brown
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question you stated earlier
just briefly a few minutes ago about
reciprocity and reciprocity is going
backwards yeah could
you then explain where a number of
licenses are starting to enter compact
is that going backwards as well uh based
on our current law I think that would go
backwards right so um if we already are
accepting licenses from every other
state why would
we require that state to accept our
license if we're already getting the
benefits of having those people move
here I mean in general compacts are fine
but uh we have a pretty good law that
already allows us to take people from
other
states represent Brown uh thank you
madam chair following up on
representative groa I I
believe it may be the same thing can you
provide any links for studies I I think
I believe you said that studies show
there really isn't an impact on Public
Safety in the in the varying differences
between licenses yeah none that I've
seen and I'll be happy to get you some
stuff uh that we have on that yeah thank
you representative gold if you if you've
recovered yes I have thank you madam
chair so um recently when I was doing
some research for another bill I
discovered a report that was done about
a dozen years
ago it was a federal report on licensing
and it was written specifically to
legislators in all the various States
comparing legislation across states are
you familiar with that report does that
ring a bell uh Federal government's done
quite a few things um during the Obama
Administration the the Obama
Administration um I think we have that
link on our website they they um
underwent a very aggressive effort to
get states to roll back their licensing
requirements because the Obama
Administration found that it
um these big differences in licensing
requirements were causing a lot of
income inequality and a lack of Mobility
right um the Federal Trade Commission in
2018 also um which I quoted in my
written testimony um has been
aggressively pushing for uh lowering
barriers to cross state um license
transportation and so you um followup
Madam chair follow up and so my question
was in response to some of that work
that research do you think that that's
been driving some of the changes you
were talking about where states are
becoming more standard no thank you
that's a great question um yeah in in so
the Biden Administration uh the Obama
Administration and the Trump
Administration all I mean this is a very
bipartisan uh thing they have all pushed
um lowering license requirements at the
state level and advancing reciprocity
and they've done that mostly because uh
the FTC Zone work some uh federal
government work but a lot of academic
research done on this across the country
at various universities has found um
remarkably similar effects uh from
Licensing Laws that reduce um Mobility
reduce employment uh pretty negative
economic effects so the economic
research on this is quite strong
follow thank you madam chair and so what
I recall from those reports is that New
Hampshire ranked pretty low in terms of
overall demands for licensing on the
citizenry percentage wise and back then
at that time and um and so even though
we have higher
requirements uh for some of our
professions I I hope we can keep our
overall numbers low uh I think there's a
gentleman in the room that could put us
um better pegged currently and where we
stand national ranking wise okay other
questions for this for the chair um so
the I he refering sending things to us I
think on prior bills people may have
mentioned that things that I haven't
seen in the email is there a mechanism
if somebody submits online to the online
testimony for us to actually get it how
does that work that's an excellent
question representative I will research
it and get back to you I just to to I I
submitted that shortly before here only
because my printer stopped working so
that's why it was submitted online um
but I can send you links and everything
else if I can do follow yeah you didn't
you did not send it to the committee as
email it it went through the online
meeting online portal correct thank you
yes I will find out how to do
that I have to apologize for not having
found out early no it it was shortly
before I got here uh thank you so much
okay thank you um Charles Powell and
Edward David from the board of
accountancy you don't mind coming
together I imagine your issues are very
similar that would be fine Madam chair
thank you for hearing
us you have to speak clearly into the
microphone thank you madam chair and
members of the
committee of course I'm here today to
speak to you with regard to um identify
your I'm about to do that thank you uh
my name is Charles Powell I'm a member
of the board of accountancy and I'm here
to speak to you about HB uh
1272 um that bill seeks to remove as you
know the requirement of substantial
equivalency for reciprocal licensing of
CPAs in New Hampshire for accountants
otherwise licensed in other
jurisdictions as an initial matter I
would Echo many of the comments of
executive executive director Courtney
and one comment in particular and that
is you got this right last year and
please don't fix what ain't
broken um on behalf of the board of
accountancy I have submitted a letter to
you that expresses our concerns and
opposition to this bill as well as HB uh
1676 which you're going to hear about uh
here shortly this afternoon
um these bills especially 1676 have
ultimately the uh the purpose of the
abolition abolition of the board and the
protections to Commerce and the public
interest by the board and excuse me Mr
Powell please do not impune the motives
you can speak to what the facts are but
please don't assume you know why
somebody did something thank you yes
Madam chair I didn't mean any uh insult
by that um I think that uh the effect of
1676 is is plain that's all I was
referring to um perhaps reading a couple
of quotes from opal C's website and from
the board's authorizing statute which is
RSA 309b will help illustrate why the
board of accountancy opposes the
legislation opl C's website states that
the board of accountancy's mission is to
ensure the applicant that applicants are
qualified for lure the board sets
standards for the profession by
proposing statutes and adopting
administrative rules investigating
complaints of unprofessional conduct and
taking disciplinary action against
lenses when necessary to protect the
public and I emphasize to protect the
public um end quote there similarly RSA
309 B2 provides as follows it is the
policy of the State of New Hampshire and
the purpose of this chapter to promote
the reliability of information that is
used for guidance in financial
transactions or for accounting uh I'm
sorry to promote the reli reliability of
information that is used for guidance in
financial transactions or for accounting
for or assessing the financial status or
performance of commercial non-commercial
and governmental Enterprises end quote
there the policies endorsed by these
references are as relevant today as
they've always been this is a serious
and vital issue the board the
requirements established by the board
and oversight by the board exists to
ensure reliability of financial
information and to protect the public as
stated by executive director Courtney
earlier today it also is intended to
protect Commerce within the state
they're not burdensome they are
necessary that's the position of the
board of accountancy hb1 1272 and other
related leg legislation such as hb1 uh
1676 We Believe will dimin Minish these
protections by eliminating the
requirements established by the board
and ultimately by completely eliminating
board oversight with regard to the
qualifications and the conduct of
persons and firms subject to regulation
under New Hampshire
law um this bill in particular in bills
under current consideration eliminate
the assurances provided by the board of
oversight by removing the board's
determination as to whether a proposed
lense E From Another state is an
appropriate leny in this state the board
does not believe that the proposed
legislation will ensure that all
potential licenses meet sufficient
benchmarks to protect the public it does
not take into account the lack of
consistency for example between
jurisdictions nor does it take into
consideration the fact that the
substantial equivalency requirement has
not even been tested this is the
requirement that was established uh last
year has not not even been tested as it
is brand new only have having been
recently enacted we believe um that at a
minimum the substantial equivalency
requirement should be tried and tested
before further alterations amendments or
modifications are contemplated We
Believe therefore that hp1 uh 1272 is
misguided and should be rejected thank
you for hearing me I'll entertain any
questions that the committee might have
your
good afternoon thank you madam chair and
rest of the committee me members for
giving me the opportunity to speak um
this is my first time doing this so I
may not be as formal as some of the
others my name is Edward C David I'm a
CPA which stands for certified public
accountant I live in
Seabrook
and we request the board of I am
currently the chair of the board of
accountancy as well so I guess I should
mention that we did have an emergency
meeting this morning to cover a couple
of these house bills and at that meeting
there was a vote taken that that we come
to you and ask for you to reject this
bill reciprocity and Mobility has been
the key to the accounting profession for
many many years our exam it's a national
exam it's an exam that is coordinated
between the American Institute of CPA
and the National Association of State
Board of accountancy this is not a
different exam by
state other parts are
different I'm going to give you a little
family story so I hope I do not bore you
with the
details again my name is Ed David 1986 I
graduated from
college by within three years I had
passed the CPA
exam I had three years of experience
what did experience mean it meant that I
Was preparing
audits reviewed level financial
statements compilations corporate tax
returns partnership tax returns
individual tax returns and Trust tax
returns I had to specify to the state of
New Hampshire the number of hours I had
in each one of these
categories so my CPA certificate from
the state of New Hampshire is dated June
of
so that's the David story since then for
almost 38 years which will be this may I
have been working in public accounting
doing those same
skills my sister-in-law
Jean I love her 1980 she graduated from
college then she went down to Texas A&M
to get to work on her Masters while she
was down there she passed the CPA exam
again the exact same exam I took Tech
Tas had no experience requirements she
became a CPA the day she passed her
test her CPE that she
takes she gets credit for the classes
she teaches as a professor my
sister-in-law again I love
her she has spent her entire career in
Academia and not once prepared an
audited financial statement a tax return
a review level financial statement she
hasn't done Consulting with contractors
and all the things that I have done over
the past 38 years so I would ask this
board are our two experiences the
same I have worked for 38 years ensuring
our public interests ensuring that the
financial statements for our clients
meet the qualifications and meet the
banking standards I have issued going
concern reports which tells the
bank this client is not doing so well
you probably should not be lending the
money because our ethics required it and
I did it and I question again with us
somebody who's been in Academia her
whole profession whether she'd be able
to so last year my brother and his wife
moved Virginia refused to Grant her a
CPA license due to the fact that her
whole career was
Academia so I humbly request that this
committee rejects this proposed house
bill as in my opinion it's going to
diminish the protection of our public
that we've been working with for so many
years thank you for your
time thank you are there any questions
from the committee representative
Schmid thank you madam chair so you
heard that this bill is going to the
subcommittee yes are one or are the
other of you available for the
subcommittee we can work that out
between the two of us actually if I may
address your question um the board has
authorized any available member of our
uh Board of accountancy to attend so
someone will be there yes that answers
my question thank you very much any
other
questions representative
Shu thank you madam chair been trying to
formulate a question
um I'm I will put this to you I'm
assuming that as members of the board uh
you folks use that language
substantially similar to apply your
practices to anything anybody applying
uh in your collaboration with oplc would
that be a true
statement it's a true statement but we
also have the assistance of the national
accounting state board um they they uh
Interlink between oplc and the different
states so they provide us with the
information as to the state rules so for
the most part we're covered on that my
my system Law's issue I don't think
anybody would ever know it thank you for
that Insight if I may add something to
that Madam chair please um the
substantial equivalency uh language is
so new that we really have had little to
no opportunity to really work with it at
this point so
um I I anticipate that it would be a
Cooperative relationship and
determinations made but again it is
extremely new thank you madam chair Yes
except that I'm sure you have had
applications from accountants from other
states ever since the board was founded
and you made judgments one at a time if
their experience was similar more yes
what has what has happened in that issue
is the O OPC reviews the uh request and
when there are issues they have brought
them to our board to oversee to see if
we can work out the issues but um oplc
has been dealing with that most of last
few years yes the board of accountancy
I'm has been around for I don't know
it's 50 years or 100 years but that
you've been around a long time and I'm
sure You'
had uh people moving to the state who
want to be accountants yes what happens
they provide us with the information
that is requested in the application
which is their um CPA license from the
init their initial State the continue in
professional education since they you
know the last three years um and they do
provide letters from I believe it's one
client one non-family member and I
forget who the may be two clients but
there's a couple series of letters that
they provide us thank
you otherone
else all right thank you very much for
your
testimony thank you madam chair and
members of the
committee Lee
mcth M chair committee
Mone thank you madam chair members of
the committee good afternoon my name is
Lee McGrath I'm a senior legislative
councel for the institute for justice uh
thank you for the opportunity to
enthusiastically uh voice my support my
colleague support for hb1
1272 I have just a couple of reasons for
why uh you should uh you should support
this bill and given it your
recommendation that it ought to p uh
pass
but more importantly I I want to respond
to some of the questions that have been
been asked here important important uh
uh
questions uh there are two main reasons
before getting to the questions there
are two main reasons for you to grab
this uh I issue uh occupational
licensing is the biggest labor market
issue in the state of New Hampshire you
own it it should not be delegated to the
executive branch you should set the
policy because in New Hampshire
approximately 17% of all workers need a
license to work that is larger than the
10% of union members and larger than the
2% of New Hampshire workers who earn the
minimum wage this is the most important
is issue in labor markets today
and I agree with my my friend Drew
kleene uh that Miss Courtney is very
talented and one of the the the best uh
executive directors in the country I put
her up up there with Vermont and Utah
and Colorado but you the voice of the
people you have the legitim the
Democratic legitim legitimacy and you
should not delegate your authority to
Governor sununu's admin Administration
for many reasons including that Miss
Courtney may go on to other
things secondly you want to reduce
burdens you do not you like you should
like this bill because it sets a
rule and you may add to it in the
subcommittee some exceptions but don't
let the exceptions Drive the the rule
the need to a question about need it was
discussed identified earlier that there
are approximately 200 licenses in New
Hampshire and only
13 have some level of recognition or or
reciprocity so let this bill be the rule
and then subsequently identify the
exceptions for some of the idiosyncratic
dynamics that exist in New Hampshire
like land surveying or or archaic real
estate
laws the second reason is well
identified Mobility you have a labor
shortage that is well identified uh in
the in this but let me jump to the
questions representative Gro you wisely
asked the question about
burdens and how New Hampshire compares
to other states my colleagues at the in
Institute for justice have have looked
at
102 low to medium skilled licenses and
New Hampshire has the 12th least
burdensome licenses that we we looked
looked at so you should not one should
not engage in this the mythology that
people from a low regulation state that
always it's always pointed out
Mississippi
are unskilled should they move to New
Hampshire the reality is that the states
that are less burdensome than New
Hampshire are Indiana Kentucky Missouri
Texas Kansas Colorado
Minnesota where I live Montana South
Dakota Vermont and W Wyoming so you
already are recognizing a lot of
licenses this Bill codifies the reality
that New Hampshire has a light touch
when it comes to the burdens that it
puts on low and medium skilled
workers representative maputi you raised
a very
important question about consumer
protection and and the evidence is clear
in Border studies where the N Center for
regulation occupational regulations out
of West Virginia has looked at
licenses in border states and there is
no evidence of the if uh that lower
burdens cause more consumer complaints
than higher higher burdens the presence
of a license is
important it has important signaling
benefits to Consumers it is a vehicle
for enforcement and someone losing their
license but the inherent difference is
not all that great as it relates to
added consumer consumer
protection representative O'Brien you
asked a question I think about
representative Fitzpatrick
representative O'Brien is not here his
proxy asked a
question oh sorry sorry representative
well if McGrath can't get differentiate
O'Brien and Fitzpatrick we are we are
lost we are Lo lost here so I think you
were the one representative Fitzpatrick
who who asked about compact about
wanting other states to represent to
allow Granite Staters to come in their
state as a prerequisite for your doing
doing that there is a compact movement
but it's a slow movement the only real
successful compact has been the nursing
Compact and New Hampshire is one of 38
states that is a member of the nursing
compact it is working the Department of
Defense recently funded 10 Mill uh $10
million to look at 10 other compacts
slow slow
slow
and this should not be the Principal way
in which New Hampshire or any other
state for that that
matter attempts to attract new employ
new employees new
workers more competition more consumer
consumer uh Cho
choices
the and finally uh M Madam
chair you have a model of
success in that this is not new it's not
new to New Hampshire and as Drew Klein
suggested that the majority of the 20
states that have introduced this do it
as representative power is suggesting
with out
substantially substantially equivalent
that
requirement Arizona was the first now
there are many reasons to move to AR
Arizona but 9,000 people have moved to
Arizona and gotten their licenses
immediately recognized when they move
there and most interesting I think for
granite Staters is that 38% of those
were building contractors so to the
extent that you have a housing shortage
you should be particularly sensitive to
reducing whatever barrier you can for
those who build new new H new houses
with that Madam chair I'm happy to
answer any questions about the work of
the institute for for justice uh what I
any questions about what's happening in
other other states or questions about CP
a or anything like that thank you there
was one question earlier that you might
have the answer to and that is specific
language from other states that have
adopted this and in particular some of
our thorny issues yes don't let uh Madam
chair members don't let the Tail Wag the
Dog if you have certain
idiosyncratic uh rules about uh real
estate or land land make the the person
coming to Vermont uh coming to New
Hampshire pass that jurisprudential
legal te
test you can put that in you can make
that a a require requirement and that I
think is the subject matter of what the
subcommittee like might look at whereas
where do you want to had the additional
requirement for a handful of licenses
where New Hampshire is particularly
idiosyncratic as it relates to
law thank you representative leus thank
you um kind of on that subject the other
issue that was raised was um differences
in scope of practice between licenses in
New Hampshire versus other states I'm
curious on the 20 states that have done
this um did they do anything to deal
with that and if so
how uh Madame chair Representative leas
no to the to the what has been happening
in the 20 States has mostly been on the
credentialing side the qualification
side it has been left up to the
counterparts of Miss uh Courtney to and
staffs like that to determine if it's if
it's apples and apples so her comments
earlier about apples and apples
comparison are very very relevant as it
relates to scope of of practice that
comes in every once in a while in the
medical Prof professions particularly
with LPNs and and and others but that is
is
uh there is such except for a few there
is such standardization in scope of
practice that uh it is been there's been
difference to uh agencies like yours
just a quick followup followup so to
make sure I understand so in those cases
where there is a non-trivial difference
in scope of practice they just don't
consider an equivalent and they don't
have reciprocity in those cases is that
correct yes thank you
okay representative G thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question regarding some of the
statistics you gave us you said that
177% of New Hampshire residents are
licensed was that correct yes and so my
question is comparing that Nationwide
you then said TW we're the 12th least
bism state but that's a different that's
a different issue uhuh and so c um can
you tell us of with a number like 177%
for New Hampshire how that compares
Nationwide it is uh Madam chair
representative ghoul it is
lower on a national basis approximately
20% of all Americans need a license to
work at 17 % New Hampshire is below
below uh uh that that number in our re
research just looking at 102 lad to
medium medium uh licenses uh New
Hampshire we consider the 41st best
state in in the nation because New
Hampshire only licenses of these
238 and the burden is light a light
touch as I expressed but don't pat
yourself too hard on your on the on the
back because Vermont is better ver
Vermont has the uh is the very be tied
with Wyoming as the very best state and
so there's a culture in Vermont to be
very skeptical about licenses and and uh
to use them very very infrequently
because they want people to be able to
pursue their
calling thank you other
questions all right thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
on House Bill
1272 all right seeing none I will close
the hearing representative laus will be
scheduling the subcommittee meeting at
his earliest
convenience and we will resume at 130
for our next
bit
for
Lord
good good afternoon uh I guess I bang
this and we
start and
what who's
up
oh okay thank
you I was just going to see what we were
doing it would appear to be
representative
leus hello thank you um uh
representative Tony luus for the record
representing uh the towns of Hudson and
Lichfield so I'm uh
introducing House Bill
1676 to establish a sunset commission to
evaluate the need for uh existence and
changes for occupational licensing and
the basic idea and first of
all uh not just from what we heard
earlier today but from email I've gotten
and people who button hold me you know
there seems to be the impression that
the effect and maybe the intent of this
bill is to get rid of Licensing and get
rid of all or particular licensing
boards and that is very far from the
truth that is not what is intended and
even if this already become law I would
be very surprised if uh any boards are
completely eliminated or any licenses I
mean it might happen but that's not the
intent um it establishes a uh Sunset
commission which is charged to review uh
evaluate the need for performance of and
possible improvements to the boards on
commissions under review and the proper
type of laws and rules regulating
occupations I would say this is similar
to the current situation where rules
expire every 10
years because that forces um a look
again by the uh you know whatever
department has issued those rules they
have to look at them again and
rejuso the joint legislative committee
on
rules and this is basically the same
thing um you know the question is um
well the purpose of Occupational
licensing there's one and only one
legitimate purpose and that is to
protect public health and safety so the
question I mean it's not to validate the
value of a
profession um or anything like that it's
to protect the people of the State of
New Hampshire and so the question is is
the current
structure of uh of the licensing regime
for a particular
profession is it still the best way to
do that um you know it could be that
there are situations where it could be
better uh do a better job of protecting
health and safety the public or there
could be uh circumstances where there
changes should be made to reduce the
burden on the people being licensed and
to allow it make it easier for people to
enter the profession but still do a good
job of protecting public health and
safety and and the reason for the
repeals is that it forces the commission
to do that job well at least hopefully
does it puts pressure on them to make
sure they review uh each one of these um
you know boards and the licenses that
they're under if you look at the statute
it requires the commission to start
looking and reviewing um each one of
those at least one year before they
expire and the reason they're done in
chunks not all at the same time is you
know if all of them expired at once that
would just be too much of our G gantu
and job for the commission to really do
an effective
job
um and so the commission will be
responsible for investigating the need
for performance of an improvements to
licensing statutes administrative rules
and boards that are scheduled to
Sunset and they're uh excuse me can you
tell us where you're at
Tony sorry I'll do that I'm on uh the
first page starting at line 22
sorry
um and and it gets then further there's
some um it's part of the charge to the
commission you know what what should
they be doing and what things should
they consider but it does not
require that they you know anything
about the final action they're going to
recommend um I mean they could decide
that everything's fine as it is and you
know there'd be um legislation which
would basically just get rid of the
repeal I mean you know we can't bind a
future legislature so if they decide
everything's fine with this board then
they would just uh submit legislation
that would would uh repeal the repeal
and everything would stay the same okay
um and um if we go down to line 26 you
know the commission's analysis may
include the laws effects and
opportunities for workers consumer
Choice cost benefits you know General
unemployment all sorts of other
things um and there there's uh that also
May doesn't require that they
compare um you know other how other
states regulate the occupation also
looking at you know scope and practice
not just what are the requirements um to
get a
license um you know penalties that are
they're imposed for violating it they
could look at you know what is the U
process for dealing with complaints uh
maybe the investigation hearing process
I mean they have a wide charge of
looking at how um you know the board and
and oplc are dealing with regulating
that profession um is it being done
efficiently is it effectively protecting
public health and and safety could it be
done better um you know and
so it gets into
here um on on the page two um line four
it starts you know the right of an
individual to pursue a lawful occupation
a fundamental right where the commission
finds it necessary to restrict that
right it shall recommend the least
restrictive regulation to protect
consumers from present significant and
substantial harms by providers of the
services and it gets into um you know
some of the options they can recommend
but it it doesn't bind them to just one
of these uh but um you know these are
it's just sort of guidance on what they
you know should be looking at or
considering um and some things that down
at line 26 the report shall include its
findings and recommendations to the
legislature to act leg legislation could
repeal the occupational license I would
be surprised if that actually you know
completely to completely get rid of it
and just let the repeal go through could
happen but I I'd be very surprised if
any of them actually go away you know
convert it into one of the less
restrictive types of
Regulation um and and there's various
other options and the last one is just
make no change to the law so you know
they they're perfectly capable of uh of
doing that so the repeals in the repeal
section are there to basically Force the
commission to do something there's been
all too many commissions I've seen and
I'm sure we've all seen that are given a
charge and they effectively do nothing
um some have never met but even ones
that meet maybe they generate some kind
of report but they don't do anything um
you know they don't do what was intended
and it's possible that could happen
happen here I mean the commission could
just recommend everything should stay
the same and legislation should be put
into repeal the repeal on all of these I
hope that's not the case and this is to
give a little push to actually take a
serious look at at you know how we're
dealing with all these professions and
how we're protecting the public and that
is the intent of
this um and this by the way is another
bill that um you know uh came out of um
uh you know the governor's office
working with oplc and others and I was
asked to take it on but this is one
where you know I really believe this is
a good idea and uh and this you know I I
had some had some in a redraft some
significant changes mainly to add more
guidance to the commission on at least
the things they should look at but not
demanding they do you know other than
they look at it demand that they take
any particular action that will be up to
the commission and um and and on page
three at the top it gets into um
commission also make comment on each
board's licensing board's composition
and the authority of the law delegates
to prom administrative rules
particularly rules relating to
establishing you know there's scope of
practice and other things so you know
they can also look at is the current
makeup of the board appropriate is it
still the best way of doing things
should there be some changes there we've
some seen some bills to make those
changes but the commission then would be
asked to look at it and review that and
say okay you know is the membership
still the best for overseeing the uh the
professions and and protecting the
public
um and then the next part of it starting
at line nine on page three are the um
repeals and so it's done in
groups um and that's you know it's just
repealing the rsa's related to it but
again you know unless the commission
does absolutely nothing and nobody puts
any legislature legislation to change it
um I don't see these repeals actually
happening but it does put in a process
that's going to require the commission
do something and hopefully hopefully to
take a good thorough and effective
review of how we're handling you know
the regulation of these professions and
are we doing it in the best way and
should there be any changes made um and
then I'm going to go to page uh
four uh line 28 starting the effective
dates and so that just goes through and
it does them um you know it sets the
effective dates so they're going to you
know when they're going to take effect
and it spreads it out from you know 2025
is the first uh set and
2031 is the LA last and then the
remainder of this act takes effect upon
passage and that's the establishment of
the commission I mean they can start
their work as soon as that takes effect
they don't have to wait um any
particular time for any of them but it
does
um put that into place I mean there is a
fiscal note I would like to defer any
questions on that to um executive
director Courtney who would have the
details on that I
don't um and that's basically it the key
thing I want to I mean I understand why
there was some confusion and there are
people who felt that the intent here you
know the whole goal of the bill is to
get rid of Occupational licensing and
that is absolutely not the case but I
understand why people felt that way uh
but it starts out with the establishment
of the commission and says they have to
start start this work um at least a year
prior to any repeal and U and that's all
I have to say and I'll be glad to answer
questions representative BR thank you um
there'll also be some follow-up question
so in the composition of the
commission typically it
says um for example when the members of
the house when the speaker appoints
members it typically mentions either
some members from the majority party or
some members from the minority party and
that's not here is there a reason for
that um the reason is it was drafted
that way and then I didn't catch it and
I would certainly be glad and I think
it's appropriate uh to amend it in that
way and and I apologize for the
oversight that was not my intent okay
follow up follow
yeah um it also doesn't um mention
members of this committee which are
members who for many years have been
involved with licensing so I would
encourage you to include that as well
and again I agree entirely with you and
um you know I looked at when I was
reviewing this um I didn't draft the
initial thing when I looked at it for
changes again I I didn't um you know I
didn't end up taking a close enough look
at that section or I probably would have
added those changes and thank you for
the uh for that that recommendation last
question thank you than you so in the
analysis the bill says the the bill
further repeals various occupational
boards and commissions each year through
2031 where does it say that this is
dependent on the commission's finding in
this document it um I didn't write the
analysis but um it in a sense it's not
it is true that if the commission
decided never to meet and never to do
anything and no but no legislator
legislator um seen that introduced a
bill to repeal one or more of the
repeals I suppose then yes they would
get repealed but I cannot imagine that
happening I can imagine I suppose the
commission not doing their job but I
can't imagine that if that were the case
that nobody would be putting in a bill
to get rid of the repeals because you
know there would be a human cry over it
and um I wouldn't support if the
commission was that derel I wouldn't uh
support necessarily leaving in all the
repeals okay I have another question now
one more so if you don't if you don't if
you don't support the repeal of these
commissions based on the lack of
activity from the commission would you
not put that in here um no I it's not
that I don't support or not support the
repeals I mean that would be up to the
commission my concern would be if the
commission chose never to
meet and and make a recommendation you
know then I that'd be irresponsible on
the people there I hope members would
get replaced um but the reason for
leaving the repeals in here is to you
know provide some impetus to the
commission
actually um you know doing something and
actually taking a look at these and I'm
sure there would be plenty of people
that would come into the commission to
you know make their arguments as both as
you know as to why um you know the
licensing you know maybe should stay the
same but um but also maybe why it should
change I um there was going to be
someone here um um you know from the uh
I can't speak from the pharmac chair
actually the chair of the pharmacy board
was going to come in and speak yeah a
family emergency he said he's going to
send in written testimony all I can say
is he told me he was actually in support
of this but for the details you'll have
to hear from
him go again
so I'm sorry to be so persistent no no
you're welcome because you know you are
a dear friend from Hudson over there I I
do not take these as an attack it's fine
go ahead but you're sort of talking from
both sides of your mouth you're saying
the commissions don't do anything and
that's why we need to do this and then
you're saying well if the commission
doesn't meet then there's nothing to
prevent these boards from being repealed
so in essence you sort of made your own
case have you not I disagree and I I uh
take somewhat umbrage at saying I'm
talking from both side of my mouth that
isn't terribly friendly um it's meant to
be friendly okay I tried really hard to
find the friendliest words I can find um
I strongly disagree with that
characterization of what I'm saying um
it is
intended to um light a fire under the
commission to take action and um again
partly my experience have seen all too
many commissions that haven't you know
you you if I just created a I had a bill
to create a commission to review
um all of the um licensing
boards um my my expectation is not very
high as to what would come out of that
um unfortunately and that's based on
experience um I mean some commissions
have done a great job others less so and
um while there's a number of output
outcomes that could come out of this as
I said um you know I don't expect the
end result is going to be repealing all
these licensing
boards um but you know the reason the
language and the repeal is in there and
I think is in there even though I don't
expect them all to get repealed is
because it causes it will cause I hope
the commission to take a serious look at
these so I again I really don't believe
I'm talking out of both sides of my
mouth and I strongly object to that
characterization and you have my sincere
apologies okay thank you
accepted
representative ghoul thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my
question I've been watching uh
representative Dolan's committee on
committees and commissions with interest
and I'm wondering does this bill have
any correlation with the work that
representative Dolan's committee is
doing on committe not that I'm aware of
I have not I mean I'm aware of that uh
what he's doing I haven't followed it in
detail but I don't I don't see that I
mean it does create another
commission uh but they have a charge you
know over some number of years to do
something and and
follow thank you for that answer I I as
I said I've been following it and
clearly there's been some um quite a bit
of testimony that's come out that there
are a number of committees and
commissions that nobody even knows if
they meet there's never been any reports
coming out of them there's no
documentation anything's
happening so I'm wondering if that in
your work in preparing the bill
representative leus did you find that
there are any similarities to that
scenario among I see that this is
limited only to the boards and
commissions under um the office of
Licensing is that correct or theol
licensing um it's the specific ones that
are listed in the repeal sect yeah and
that's all to do with licensing right so
I'm wondering if it was found that there
are instances like that within the
listed Boards of there's a question are
they even
meeting a lack of um knowledge about
what they're doing that this bill could
be a solution to it would get people's
attention to what are they doing I
suppose I mean you know it the duty of
the commission is to look over you know
the both the statute the actual act
membership and activity of the board and
Associated administrative rules that are
um you know that exist for regulation I
suppose if they found that the thing
ineffective they could decide anything
from changing abolish it changing the
membership or whatever they recommend I
mean it it might be effective to the
extent it would it'd have somebody
taking a look at it and then reporting
on what they're doing I don't know if
there actually are existing licensing
boards that are in that state but one
more thank you Mr chair and um
thank you so in followup I will say I've
gotten a lot as I've talked to my
constituents and friends and colleagues
about following the committee on
commissions and committees um I get a
lot of Chuckles about all right yeah and
so to here that we're gonna have another
committee on commissions and is we don't
even know if that's dob tailing with the
existing one makes me
wonder if yeah I what I would say is
this really is not a
general um committee dealing with
commissions that it's main it's dealing
with um you know the
licensing um and also I expect this
would become a very high-profile one I'm
sure there's going to be a lot of
interest in it and I think that makes it
less likely that it's going to not meet
and not do anything and and also uh kind
of a follow up on the question about the
repeals um you know
you know worst case the commission
doesn't do
anything um I cannot as I the reason I'm
saying I don't see even in that case I
don't see the repeals actually Tak to
effect is you know given all the people
that are licensed or have an interest in
licensing I cannot imagine that you're
not going to have somebody get some
representative or Senator to put in a
bill to make the repeals not happen if
the commissioner were derel in in their
Duty I mean that you know there there're
probably more things unlikely than that
but there's not a lot of them in my
view representative man
boy thank you um Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I have couple of qu I
have couple of questions one is to start
with by setting up a committee
commission to study the commission
statuary
commissions
within the time frame this body turns
over every two years so how do you
maintain a a
continuity on who's on the committee I
mean who's on the commission and what is
are you expecting the commission to do
their due diligence
within the given period the this
particular uh session this two years or
is it a continuity because the
appointment to these commissions can
change every two
years that that's correct um there I
mean the way this is set up their work
would continue over um a period of years
because it's just impractical it's too
much work if they're going to do any
kind of reasonable job to do all of them
in one twoyear period and that's why you
know it's it's staggered when uh the
particular um board boards are going to
be or have the repeal in
place um you know like I mean you can
ask the same question about the entire
New Hampshire legislature you have um
you know you have a mix of turnover and
continuity you have Representatives that
are in for quite some time and you have
people that are in for one two three
terms and I would expect something
similar with this
um and uh so you know probably you'd
have some new people and some people but
they're going to be dealing probably I
mean they could decide to start working
early you know some years in advance on
one of the ones that's going to get
repealed but the way it's set up you
know they're going to be working on
different professions different
boards um you know probably on a yearly
basis so they can do things in parallel
they can start things
early but um it's not like there's they
don't I mean they're going to have work
product regularly because they have to
put out a report on the particular
boards and professions and you know you
whether they're all you know it's always
the same people or not I mean you know
you can argue whether that's a good
thing or a bad thing having some you
know people may get burnt out or tired
having new people in there is not
necessarily A Bad Thing keeping some
people in there who have experienced
doing it it's not a bad thing either uh
but same thing with the whole house I
mean we have that going on here
followup uh a followup yes yeah having
serving on the sixth consecutive term
and having been on different commissions
it changes every two years which
commission you get on or not based on
the
majority the goals that you set today
you're trying is this bill trying to set
a goal for the future legislation
telling this is what you need to do this
is 2026 2028 this is what is going to
isn't that something that goes totally
against what our legislation says we
cannot hold the future legislation
binding to some of the changes that we
are expecting to happen no um it is true
that uh one legislature cannot bind a
future legislature but if you look at it
there there are certainly plenty of
bills that are passed that have ongoing
effects and if um you know a future
legislature decides this whole thing's a
bad idea there's nothing that prevents
them from repealing the statute
including the repe the future repeals
that are in it so I'm not you know we're
not binding a future legislature we we
you know if we pass this we would be
setting a process in in in in effect
that at least I would hope would
continue forward until completion which
is going to be across multiple
legislatures but you know I'm not we
can't bind them we're we're just trying
to get something going and provide some
direction to the commission and if a
future legislature doesn't agree with
doing that they don't have to do
it representative
goalie thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking
questions I'm looking at first I want to
go back to what representative gr up GR
up uh the makeup of
the
commission why on line 16 the governor
has two positions and then on line 21 he
has three more
positions he or she as going
forward okay um and first of all I mean
I've been assured this is going to sub
committee and I will gladly accept
suggestions for amendments in particular
to this section which I know needs it
um yeah I can see the issue there maybe
it should be changed I mean the idea was
to have a couple of members that kind of
represent the governor's View and then
have public members but the way things
are set up if you look in in other for
other boards the public members are are
uh I think they're appointed by the
governor if I'm wrong I'd be glad to
change this um but I can see the concern
that in effect he's appointing um too
many people and uh I you know we I can
ask director Courtney or look at other
statute on
how um how the public I mean there
they're going to be any of the members I
think are generally and this may to be
changed if it's not clear in here uh you
know uh
um they're proposed by somebody but then
they're they're basically appointed by
the governor and confirmed by counsel
and that's true I think for all the
boards um but it may be there needs to
be um you know the recommendations on
them may need to come from somebody else
whether it's oplc for the public members
uh to come for oplc or whatever I know
there's a problem finding public members
actually if you look hopefully in the
next calendar representative Gro and I
have a memb notice in there asking all
representatives to uh who presumably
know people in their Community to
recruit people uh for being public
members for all the boards um but yeah I
can see the concern about that and i'
certainly probably you know may very
well need to be changed thank you
followup and going along with the
membership of the commission I I just
have an issue with the
left real broad as to who can be
appointed there's no specification
whether it should be someone who's even
licensed by the state of New Hampshire
which I think is important to have on a
commission like this um to
represent I you know the the concern
about having um you know representation
majority and minority P party I think is
important uh maybe specifying that that
some of the people have to come for
particular committees Edna for example
um is important but
there I I don't think requiring that
they be licensed there's going to I mean
licensing the purpose of Licensing in my
view is not for the lenses at all the
purpose of Licensing is to protect
public health and safety now certainly
the commission's going to have people
who have an interest who are licensed
before them uh you know providing
testimony and their reasons for why I
mean a lot of it may be that it just say
the same but you may I know there's
going to be some coming forward who
think there should be changes and you
know that's something for the commission
to take a look at but I you know I
wouldn't prohibit anybody's license from
being on the board at all but I don't I
don't think it should be made a
requirement either
follow would you not agree that many
commissions out there have all the
stakeholders
involved when you're looking at a
particular issue
um yes they do and and again
um you know while parts of this bill I
changed and
redraft I I didn't take a careful look
at this part this is as it came from the
governor's office and and I'm you know
seriously open to any kind of
suggestions on um you know how the
membership should be structured and you
know if if you can make the subcommittee
mean that be great or not if you could
you know send something in and uh you
know that I think is a probably the the
part of this that that in my view would
need the most work and I agree with that
and one last
follow
I just have never seen and my question
goes to you may be have explained it
already but why the repeals are in here
all on the surise that we're holding the
feet to the fire on a commission to do
their work I've never seen a commission
formed with something in there to say
here do this or else and even if they do
something there's nothing to prohibit a
repeal and the the the
uh a comparison I would make that it's
not a a a commission but it's the whole
uh administrative rules process I mean
they expire every 10 years and if the
department um does doesn't do anything
then they're going to go away right now
do go rules go away in Job Lots um I
don't I haven't seen it and it's
basically the same sort of thing I mean
and again what that the you know the the
expiration on the rules is the same
thing it requires it it forces a review
of the rules first by the department and
then by the legislature at least you
know Jael car every at least every 10
years and it it's basically the same
idea
I one last
fa I guess my question is to have the
repeals in here now and you're saying
it's the force commission to do
something and those in these licensing
positions to hold the commission to
their feet to the fire to keep these
from being
repealed goes against why all these
folks are here today the hearing is
about the repeals in this legislation
they're here today not at the commission
level they're here today for this
correct right I understand that and I
understand why people had that view
however um let's say you know all the
rules oplc rules or rules for a
licensing board went away it would in
effect almost have the same effect right
because most of the licensing details on
licensing and how they're granted are
are done through you know 541a
rulemaking Authority that's granted it
was originally to the boards and now to
the you know boards and
oplc and I under this is new and I
understand why people are concerned
about it but they're just as much under
threat of their license going away if
the rules expired and nobody does
anything about it so I I understand the
concern and and that's part of why I'm
trying to you know up front explain what
this is trying to do and what I you know
expect the effect is but I think there's
just as much a chance of of all the
administrative rules on oplc evaporating
as there are of of you know the boards
evaporating and for similar
reasons representative Brown uh thank
you chair uh and thank you for taking my
question representative leus and since
I'm on your subcommittee we'll talk
about this some more um but to follow up
to fog a dead horse representative groda
and representative
goalie when I first read this at a dead
reading it says these repeals will take
place it doesn't say
what what you want it to say how's that
so I I'm hoping that in the subcommittee
that you can you can commit to having a
conversation about make making that more
clear certainly um I mean in the
statement of purpose um in the last
sentence it says the purpose of this act
is to require the legislature to
reexamine the licensing Boards of the
state to determine if it is in the best
interest of the consumer health and
safety of the state to renew their
Authority and really you know it's kind
of expanded later that could be expanded
to renew their Authority um or or make
you know changes to it or something like
that any any um any changes they they
view as necessary and uh you know I'd be
glad to add something else in there
about you know the purpose is is to um
to require this review you know not to
just get rid of the board WS or some
language like that I mean I'd be
perfectly happy to add that if it's
going to make people more comfortable
with
this go ahead representative groda I I
do want to address this comparison to
rules and I have members of the members
of this committee who have been on Jael
car as I am now but I can tell you that
rules do expire however during that
process they can be conditionally
approved they can be we adopted there is
a mechanism for them to continue so I
don't think
that um it's and that mechanism doesn't
exist here you can't just like get rid
of Licensing and then six months later
decide oh well we want it back do you
understand does that analogy makes sense
you I understand um you know there is
nothing to
prevent uh either the commission to
recommend legislation or any legislator
you know a rep or a senator to um to put
put in a bill to to repeal the repeal or
any particular one if they think I mean
if the commission thinks they need more
time and they want to change when the
repeal is going to occur or get rid of
it you the legislature is perfectly
capable of doing that um or um you know
again as I said if they're not doing
their job the say any legislature can
put in a bill and and you know if it's
going to be something crazy like you
know you get you're going to repeal the
Board of Medicine or something I don't
think there's going to be a problem
either having somebody put bill in or
getting it passed right I mean it's uh
that I see consent calendar in its
future if um either the board isn't
doing its job or maybe the board decides
they need more time there's no no reason
why they can't delay it or remove that
repeal um I agree it's not automatic but
in effect it's going to be kind of
automatic because this then this is
going to be more visible than a
particular rule expiring probably in
most cases
so representative maputi
oh never mind no more questions and oh
was
thatou thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative leus once
again as the conversation has gone on
kind of building off some of the
previous questions I recall I don't
recall us as a committee forming a
commission or having a bill to form a
commission before us last year but 10
years ago when the commission on Native
Affairs was formed I was heavily
involved in that and it was part of the
language of that commission that it
would sunset at the end of five years so
when the Sunset date came it was
incumbent upon us to put a bill in to
continue it and it did successfully be
continued it was a good opportunity to
make some changes we removed the
genealogist position I was the
genealogist and I wanted to be removed
and I supported the position being
removed so it my point being it gave a
good opportunity for a review and some
revisions and then by removing the
sunset Clause it was like it took away a
known
review and um and things changed the
Dynamics of the board did change and not
for the better Quorum got harder things
just got tougher for the commission so
my question is is this isn't this the
same language that we saw standard in
the commission on Native Affairs and
most commissions that were form Med and
has that changed I I'm not familiar with
the exact language on that uh but to
your
concern I mean there there is a valid
concern there I wasn't worried about it
which maybe was a u oversight on my part
um because the repeals sort of Drive the
work of the commission and they happen
at certain dates and so the last one
being on July 1st of 2031 and in effect
at least the way I was thinking about it
is the work of the commission
would be done at that point but you're
correct there isn't an explicit sunset
on the commission and I'd be glad to add
that that's actually you know a good
idea um it would Sunset the sunset
commission exactly so which I'm fine on
or the legislature could decide they
want it to continue and maybe you know
at some interval in the future uh you
know go basically through it again or
whatever would be up to the leg I don't
expect to be in the legislature at that
time it' be up to them and uh and and
but but you know there wouldn't be this
push for the commission to do anything
after that date uh because nothing else
is going to be sunsetting you know
nothing else going to be repealed and if
they you know I suppose if we don't put
a repeal in they could keep meeting if
they want and talk about what they think
of the boards and suggest legislation
but at least the core of their purpose
would be done and adding a sunset on
that date or you know would probably be
a good idea thank
you
representative
Shu thank you Mr chair um I am looking
oh dear I just lost it again hang on I'm
looking at um chapter
219 of 2022 that was established by
Senate Bill 330 bill that came to this
committee what what was that again
excuse me Senate Bill 330 and this
chapter chapter 219 thank you that's the
chapter law that established a committee
to study and make
recommendations relative to the office
of professional lure and
certification and The Lure of
professions under boards councils and
commissions uh what's wrong with having
that committee do the work that you're
talking about so
um I apologize when when was that formed
and 2022 okay and did they H you know in
that bill were they supposed to come up
with a report at some point and if they
were did they um well I'm not sure but
it could I have not read further down
but I'm sure there is some sort of
report that they're supposed to put out
but regardless that committee exists and
sounds like it could do the work that
you want why not just amend that chapter
and well if you we could we could do I
mean what they don't have
is um two things one at least I don't
believe I haven't read it I mean I'm I'm
pretty sure they don't have the repeals
to push them to actually do something by
certain
dates and um and there's some details in
here on the duties and kind of Direction
which I suspect is not in that one so I
I agree there there it sounds like
there's some duplication it' be
interesting to look at what if anything
that commission has
done and I mean to avoid duplication
either suppose that one could be
repealed or that one could be amended to
do what this is or you know I'd be open
to any of that but but I think you know
having some um Direction on how to do
the review not some again that may may
some of that may be in there I don't
know but not some general charge to kind
of look at it which I don't think tends
to be all that effective and then uh
then I think the repeals are a key part
of this to actually make sure we or make
it much more likely we'll get a a result
out of
it thank
you I believe that was everybody uh
thank you representative leas and thank
you next up director
Courtney oh representative leus if you
could fill out a pink card the clerk
would love
it or at least like
it
good afternoon Lindsay Courtney
executive director office of
professional lice Insurance
certification uh the office is not
taking a position on this bill but I
wanted to um make myself available to
answer any questions that you may have
regarding how we would implement this um
and also to offer a few
observations um as to what's going on in
the field of Occupational regulation
Nationwide um but before I get into that
representative Shu I wanted to answer
your pre question regarding the
committee established by Senate Bill 330
they are um no longer active um they did
have a very
productive um fall that year um they had
a series of meetings many stakeholders
attended they issued a report and the
report essentially became the Genesis
for several pieces of legislation last
year which was
655 uh which turned into 409 as well as
337 and some other pieces of legislation
so
um I just wanted to to to answer that
question um but I guess what I would
offer on the idea of sunsetting it's we
are seeing that this is an
increasingly
um uh popular if you will um approach to
um ensuring that the legislature is
consistently reviewing statutes
regarding occupational uh regulation I
think in many states um it takes the
same approach that is proposed by this
bill which is essentially to have um a
self-imposed accountability system
whereby you know the statutes are
prospectively repealed and it forces the
legislature to file a bill at some point
like something has to be filed in for in
order for um for the practice acts to
continue another approach that we've
seen Nationwide is what um others have
suggested on this committee which is
just a a commission um you know from a
policy standpoint that's certainly
another way to approach it um the
difference being that um legislation
does not have to be filed so I think the
question for this committee is to really
consider you know do you want um you
know do you want that that sort of
accountability structure um regarding
the fiscal note I would say that um
essentially what we did to calculate
that is we took whatever the revenue is
that uh these boards uh generally
generate um and we just uh we just
projected that as a loss if if the um
boards were to be repealed um on the
expenditure side uh same thing um we
just projected that um as a a cost
savings measure so I'm happy to answer
any questions but that's generally um
how we calculated
that which in order of which I saw them
representative goalie goes thank you Mr
chair
thank you director for taking my
question
certainly when you talk
about the sunset provisions and seeing
them that's not going on here in New
Hampshire currently correct is that
other states you're talking no correct
that's n that's a nationwide approach
you know we see that popping up um as
there is a um increasing scrutiny as it
relates to occupational licensing and
how it impacts Workforce and so many
states have responded by in that they're
regularly reviewing those
statutes so
well I don't take lightly the fact that
we don't follow up looking at our
statutes because being here on adna for
a number of years I think this committee
sees a lot of Licensing bills and are
pretty well in tune to what's going on
over in your office and with
licensing
um so while you say to hold the feet to
the fire to the
legislature would you not agree that I
think this committee is pretty well in
tuned as to what's going on in your
office and throughout the state
in
licensing yes I don't agree I I don't
disagree with that at all I would I
would say I feel like I live here six
months in the year as well but um but
and I'm not taking a position as to what
approach is the better approach I'm just
explaining that these are different
approaches that other states have taken
depending on you know the policy
decision of what you would like to see
thank you I I would say Mr chair that we
don't need legislation to hold our feet
to the fire I think we do our job here
on this
committee thank representative manui oh
oh you next okay sorry that's okay how
do you see the um one of the results of
that Senate bill was not only this
commission but the oplc oversight
committee so how do you see that working
excuse me isn't that also a source of
future legislation as
well yes absolutely that is something
that I think you know we've only had two
meeting one two uh meetings um so far
but certainly that could provide a
source of of future
legislation
representative manuti thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question I have
two part question one
is you know New Hampshire has the
largest body of volunteer legislation
holding a volunteer legislation feet to
the fire I don't know where you're going
to get
it can't hear you over
here thank
you I said New Hampshire has one one of
the large volunteer legislation holding
volunteer legislation feet to the fire I
don't know how far we can get at the
same time isn't this kind of holding the
future legislation accountable you got
to do something by setting other
states none of the other states have the
legisl legislation like we have the
large body of
legislators
correct I I don't know that I would
agree with that I think it's pretty
common to see legally right to see
perspective repeals um and at any given
time the legislature has the authority
to make a decision to eliminate that
perspective repeal so I don't
necessarily uh agree with that I would
also say again not taking a position
that the flip side of of that statement
is that because there's about 400 of you
all it takes is somebody in a grocery
store to run into a representative to
say hey this is a problem and a Bill
gets filed so one could make the
argument that um it's actually easier
and there's easier access to um to uh to
our Civic um you know system here um
than other states and I would agree with
that
so so I guess those would be my comments
I I mean I Echo represented LA's
comments I mean I don't see any of these
boards being repealed practically um
which is probably why I didn't have the
same reaction that some of our our other
constituents had um you know and then
there's multiple ways to approach the
issue of a legislative review as I've
noted representative G thank you Mr
chair and thank you director for taking
my question uh as I asked representative
leus are you aware whether
representative Tom Dolan's committee on
studying committees and commissions is
looking at the same um committee boards
and commissions that are on this list my
understanding of that is that that is
for legislative commissions I could be
wrong um but these are these are
different types of commissions because
they they fall within the executive
branch thank
you thank you very time thank you
director
Courtney um representative Maguire
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Carol Maguire representing
marac District 27 the towns of
Allenstown Dunbarton Epsom and hookit
and I'd like to present
a more of a broader view of this
Commission because we
create so many structures and then we go
on and we wrote and there's a lot of
turnover we end up with a lot of
artifacts in our statutes and our
organizations for example we have I
don't know how many dedicated funds and
there is a standing committee that meets
and reviews a quarter of them every year
to say do we still need this is it still
active can we fix it is there a problem
and they and they look at
every dedicated fund every four
years sometimes in more intensity than
others we can combine these or whatever
so and the we have oversight committees
we have legislative standing
committees but we end up with a lot of
stuff that gets put into law that is not
looked at for a long time U and with all
due respect to representative goal yes
we do look at it when somebody brings it
to our attention if somebody brings in a
bill on a type of license we look at it
we examine it we fix it but there are
other professions that don't have issues
and they don't come to us or we don't
have
bills and we don't know anything we
don't look into whether we need it
whether it's appropriate we we're very
reactive this commission is set up to
look at it whether it's working or not
and say yes the board of account
understands what their rules are we need
to have this they're
good and and look at the next one in the
list and say yes we have we have a
question about how we license our body
artists for example and
so we this commission would would on a
structured basis look at all of the
professions that have been licensed for
one reason or another for more than the
past years and say yes we did it right
or well maybe we can make it a little
bit
better and based on the experience of
having been on a committee on
committees um 10 year sorry 15 years ago
you know you look at them and there are
some that were started with great
enthusiasm and went on for a year or two
or three and then they faded out nobody
nobody paid any attention to them and so
every 10 years or so we have a committee
on committees to go through and look for
them the dedicated funds gets looked
at like every four years because there's
so many of them and we need to do that
because we keep accumulating all this
house all this stuff and we need to keep
track of it and clean house um
so whether or not you think that all of
our licensing statutes are
perfectly correct as they are today
which may be your position or whether
you think they're all wrong it still
doesn't matter whether you think they
should be looked at and verified on a
regular basis by somebody that is doing
it in an organized
fashion representative Shu I'm sorry
yeah no I'm representative hi I'm sorry
I'm represent gr right that's okay so um
representative McGuire it's not that we
is not that I can speak for myself I
agree with you I understand but it is
the resistance I'm I'm a pretty good
reader and I can comprehend pretty well
and many of us have comprehended this
bill in the same way as the analysis
which we're not really talking about
reviewing we're talking about we're
concerned with the repeat healing part
so if if it were just merely and I've
I've mentioned this and well I've I've
received a lot of resistance to changing
any of that so if there's some some sort
of compromise that we can make where
we're talking about the reviewing of
these things there is no doubt in my
mind that there could be improvements
made if we review but if a gun is put to
my head and I have to I've got so many
times so much time to look at it or it's
going to repeal that's a completely
different message would you agree um
I don't actually see it that way myself
but I can see where you might
and um that's one of the reasons it's
going to subcommittee to see how to
implement the goal of this bill without
uh causing so these concerns thank you
so much I appreciate
it representative
goalie thank you Mr chair
sorry represent Maguire you've been
around here as long as I have and looked
at the makeup of this committee
and how often it has changed with new
members coming on and in and
out as well as the makeup of the
house and when I look
at the makeup of this commission and the
length that's put
together I can
see where this commission starts going
One
Direction there's a change in a corner
office or a change in the senate or a
change in the house the members change
and all the work that was just done is
all of a sudden going the other
way
and in all fairness to say the repeal of
Licensing is tied to a commission
getting its work done when we here at
the legislature really have no control
of the members of that commission four
years from
now that's the issue I have do you not
agree that that could
happen I agree that the membership of
the commission could change with a
change in the governor or a change in
the structure of the house I mean that
that it's happened half a dozen times
since I've been here but
the the analysis that the commission
does even if it's slanted to some degree
would still be useful and it would still
re and it would um and as far as the
repeal goes that's something that I
think we need that the subcommittee
needs to take a look
at representative man maputi thank you
Mr chair thank you representative for
taking my
question
I look at this as
a holding the body the commission pun
very punitive angle is that because if
you don't do this this is what's going
to happen so is it fair to say that we
can have that kind of influence in terms
of for the current existing commission
that's going to be formed or the future
commissions what
what I'm I'm sorry I don't understand
which commissions you're talking about
the commission to study the commission
and the repeal the this bill that's oh
this commission created by this bill is
the one corre talking correct yeah it's
it's
not I always hesitate to judge
somebody's motives because people do
things for the weirdest reasons and very
rarely for the reasons that I think
would make sense so I don't I assume I
don't know why you're doing it all I can
do is say this is what you want to do
and I signed off on this bill because I
said we need to look at these things
this creates a structured manner to do
so and I think it's necessary we
keep um anybody who has
seen two
separate uh versions of a committee on
committees 10 years apart knows that you
know we accumulate clutter in our laws
and so this is house this is a
housekeeping measure God forbid that I
should say
so but it is it cleans up our statute
and as is the case when you do your your
housekeeping you make discover wow this
is really nice I found some good stuff I
didn't know I
had and I'm not expecting this to go
around repealing all these licenses I
think that what will happen is that we
will look at the composition of the
board and and say this is good for the
most part there but there are obviously
going to be some
issues thank you representative
Maguire representative infantine
assuming I'm pronouncing that correctly
infantine oh right Co they've done
worse good afternoon folks my name is uh
will infantine I represent Manchester
I'm the chairman of the labor committee
uh I'm also I serve as a vice chairman
of the New Hampshire electricians board
and uh speaking of myself not the board
I'm opposed to the parts of the bill
about the um Sun setting of The the
boards commissioner
Courtney stepped into a job I don't
think she knew how messed up things
probably were uh she's done a fantastic
job of trying to organize things you
different letterheads different
organizations some groups have 11 board
members and they can never meet a quorum
uh the electricians board you get your
uh uh on the job hours and you get the
class and then you can apply to get your
license uh have to come in front of the
board if maybe you have a felony or
something like that some of these other
boards are very subjective you have to
complete an essay no rules about what
the essay should say who's um grading it
to decide whether or not you get your
license um one of them uh what I'm led
to believe if they don't like that
person because they don't want more
competition they don't give them a
license so obviously there's there's
some things that that um Chris Courtney
has had to do to kind of reain things in
now this bill from my understanding
comes down from the governor's office I
spoke to the governor at length about
oplc he wants to bring more people into
the state that can work he wants to
bring more people in for jobs and he
doesn't want uh licensing to be a
hindrance um and I can respect that but
every board has its certain purpose now
some of them don't work some of them
should be Consolidated I've seen the
bills that are coming in front of you
there's a couple bills I think two
individual bills for consolidation of
certain boards those are all good and
positive
things um my concern with the sun
setting is when you get rid of a board
you get rid of the institutional
knowledge that has to do with that
industry I am not an electrician I am
the one public member that is not an
electrician but the others are so when
someone comes in front of the board
because they violated a rule um and or
and they need to come in front of us to
get a bad boy slap uh we can find them
we can uh suspend their licenses and and
do all kinds of other things to try to
enforce uh the rules that we have in
place if these boards Go away You're
left with
oplc to manage the administrative work
to manage the investigations to manage
the discipline and I'm not sure that all
being in one place is right another
position I have being the chairman of
the labor committee is to be um a member
of the New Hampshire
unemployment Securities advisor Advisory
board so once a quarter we meet with the
Advisory Board to find out what's going
on with unemployment if there are
complaints against unemployment how
they're working and it was very
important during the
pandemic and New Hampshire you know New
Hampshire's different you know we all
like to say that we're better than
everybody and we do things in the New
Hampshire way but in that capacity on
the on the Advisory Board to Employment
Securities we get to question what's
going on what's not working what needs
to be done and I like having
individuals in the state to be able to
question politely what the uh
Departments of our state are
doing and I'm much more comfortable with
electricians dealing with electricians
and and uh Landscape Architects dealing
with landscape architect issues and and
all the other different commissions that
we have versus members of the oplc that
may be lawyers or maybe lay people that
don't know anything about some of these
so it concerns me greatly that you would
Sunset some of these boards on the other
hand change is difficult people push
back on change there's been a lot of
change the
oplc I I give commissioner Courtney
credit for for her efforts and I think
more of her efforts have been positive
than
negative um but let's not dismantle this
whole thing all right they serve a
purpose some don't get rid of the ones
that don't meet get rid of the ones that
don't care about their industry enough
to have a board consolidate the ones
that want to be Consolidated with
similar type boards but um I I'm greatly
opposed to this sunsetting and I I hope
um I hope you will uh study all you want
but don't even think about the
sunsetting of some of these important
boards thank
you representative
Gould thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question my question is are you
concerned that your board if it were um
reviewed by a commission would be at
risk of being um supported by the
commission to see it
repealed well I don't we I'm not
concerned with the the board I'm on at
all quite frankly we didn't miss a beat
we didn't miss a a meeting during covid
we met we continue to meet we always
have a quorum uh sometimes we're a pain
right uh sometimes we we we push back
and and ask a lot of questions uh but no
I I
I um I think we do it well I think we do
it the way it was intended thank you
then I think that speaks to what I see
is happening with these repeals that
it's just an opportunity opportunity to
review an opportunity to motivate and an
opportunity as the chairman said to
clean house which without cleaning house
and you even alluded to some of the
other boards it's always those other
boards that are the problem right and
commissions but if there are boards that
are doing nothing they really do need to
be identified and this provides a
structure I but I congratulate you for
running a good board thank
you representative
goalie thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my questions
as a former chair of Labor where you sit
now
um you've been around here long
enough I'm sorry to say you and I have
been around here probably way too long I
know
um looking
at sunsetting some very important
boards uh for putting the feet to the
fire of a commission to do their work
work
that we all know if we've been around
here long enough that any commission
that does work and files their report of
recommended
changes does not necessarily mean those
changes will be implemented by a future
legislature going forward is that not
correct well of course I mean if if this
legislature has a study in in in
November decides to have the report done
um next year there's a new
legislature um could be different
chairman could be different uh uh
parties in in power and a lot of
different things as you and I know
things ebb and flow from year to year
um so I I guess of course it doesn't
necessarily mean each legislature will
follow it and then they could override
two years later what the previous
legislature put in place so do you think
it's fair that the electrician board's
feet are held to the fire of losing
their ability because of a commission
that their report is not bound by the
future
legislature I don't think any board is
above reproach any board is above being
looked at um some uh we had a situation
you all read and saw on TV about a
massage therapist that was doing some
inappropriate things up in the north
country and and the board was able to
take their license away and act quickly
um some boards you know you don't do
things right on the electricians board
you can get electrocuted or kill people
um that's a little different maybe from
the landscape AR Architects or what have
you uh but each has its own purpose but
again each one is open to review at any
given time there was one board I don't
recall the name where the governor got
mad and made a public display and said
if if you don't meet we're going to
disband you or get new people and
replace you um and some boards do not
take it as seriously in others
um so everyone is is is worth like I
said everyone's above reproach no one's
above approach and they can all be
looked at at any given time um I think
sunsetting some of these important
boards went way above and beyond uh what
I think is necessary at this
point
thank you I'm gonna thank you
representative go back uh representative
Schmidt thank you Mr chairman for the
record I am representative Peter Schmidt
representing uh straford District 19
which is do Ward 1 uh which I've had the
privilege of representing for the past
years um and and I've been on this
committee for 17 or 18 of those years um
and I've seen this bill
before um and um at least substantial
portion of it um and
the the the uh committee from roughly
eight years ago uh had
um had this bill itl this bill um and uh
that itl got overturned on the house
floor but um it got killed in in the
Senate um but this
is I
I'm very much aware of the fact that
that this hearing is being
recorded and and
I I call upon the people of State of New
Hampshire to pay attention of what's
going on with this
bill because this bill is a frontal
assault on a structure that's been being
developed in this state for over a
hundred years we've had had a Board of
Medicine and a board of nursing and uh
and various other crucial boards and the
people who per who those boards govern
and license have been providing
dentistry and and doctoring and
nursing um and
electrician uh service and so forth uh
for a hundred years and plenty of other
or um boards that have been put together
during that time and this this bill it
says it right out just look at it turn
to page
two line
26 the commission's report shall include
its findings and recommendations to the
legislature to enact legislation that a
repeals the occupational
licenses now I think this my experience
is everybody on this Commission on this
committee knows
English couldn't be clearer than right
there recommendations to the legislature
to enact legislation that repeals the
occupational
licenses
B converts the occupational licenses to
a less restrictive
regulation right there black and
white and go on and look
at page
three line
22 well let's look first it's line 18
says the following chapters are hereby
repealed in
2026 line 22 the board of accountancy I
think we have a couple of people here
today might have something to say about
that line 24 Board of barbering
cosmetology and Aesthetics well there
are something like
25,000 cosmetologists in the state of
New
Hampshire line
32 the board of of
medicine
repealed line 34 the Board of Nursing
repealed line 36 the Board of Pharmacy
repealed page
four line one Boards of Professional
Engineers and land surveyors
repealed line nine electricians board
repealed
line 14 mechanical licensing board
repealed line 21 real estate appraiser
board repealed a 922 Real Estate
Commission
repealed what do you think it's going to
do to the professions that take care of
the the health of the people of this
state their most valuable possession
their home or their place of
business this this bill is not some kind
of a review it is a frontal assault on
the on the the economy and the
well-being of the citizens of this
state I hope that there will be not one
vote on this Committee in favor of this
bill certainly won't come out of here
with a
majority I'm prepared to ask answer any
questions you may have but this is not
uh you know
the chojan horse this is a banai
charge a frontal
assault on the structure of this
state representative goul has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question you were reading to us from
page
two uh starting on line 26 and you read
down through 28 29 which was A and B of
that section and that section goes down
to line 36 what does line 36 say under
that
section
936 on page two says makes no changes to
state law correct so am I Incorrect and
my understanding here is that the the
list that started with repeals the
occupation licenses is the first of a
long list of possibilities or guides is
what I heard the representative say who
introduced the bill and that that list
of recommendation ends with a
possibility that the commission could
make no changes to the state law could
just leave the board or the commission
alone is that am I misunderstanding that
well this this bill is so wrongheaded in
so many ways I don't know how it can
turn right and left at the same time but
the bottom line is that for one thing
this this is going to be one hell of a
commission to serve on because when when
I was sitting in rep's Hall
about 12 years ago under the reign of
error and Terror of former speaker Bill
O'Brien rep's Hall was filled with
people but they weren't Representatives
mostly they were representatives of the
boards and professions that were going
to be
deregulated by a bill that was offered
at that particular time and every one of
the people who got up and spoke said
please don't re please don't deregulate
my profession or our profession
fession and if you just listen one after
another all the boards that were listed
were going to be repeat
deregulated and there were several
hundred people in rep's Hall saying
don't do this to
us well that bill didn't go anywhere but
they came back uh with a slightly
revised and slim down bill um that bill
didn't go anywhere either because one of
the one of the uh one of the professions
that was going to be deregulated was
guides and and former speaker Jean
Chandler who was a committee chair at
that time I believe he got up and and
said uh want to floor Amendment want to
strip that out because if you if you go
out in the woods with a guy that doesn't
know what he or she is doing you can
wind up dead in the state of New New
Hampshire and since that that re that
removal didn't happen all of his people
voted no so th this bill is such a
monstrosity I can't imagine that the
that the house is going to possibly
repeal this but we should we should
unanimously itl this bill because uh the
the commission that's set up who's going
to want to serve on that because it's
it's it's hearings are going to be one
profession after another coming up
saying don't do this to
us and with plenty of good reasons
because you're torpedoing the economy of
this
state thank you representative
Schmidt next Mr Ned Gorman Gordon
sorry
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Ned
Gordon I live in the town of
Bristol I come here today with regard to
the bill um
1676 and particularly in regard to the
provision of repealing the Guardian at
lien
board having looked at the bill uh I
really I have no objection to the idea
of a commission although I might have
some thoughts as to how it might be
provided for in a little bit different
manner than it's been
proposed uh my main concern is the
repeal as it's currently presented for
the guardian at Lim
board currently the guardian the lighten
board is to be repealed as of July 1st
I familiar with Guardian at lims I'm
familiar with Guardian at lims as a
legislator as a as a attorney as a judge
and now I sit on the guardian of lim
board as a public me member appointed by
the
governor uh I over 20 years ago I
sponsored the legislation creating the
Govern the guardian at lium board uh
prior to that time Guardian Lems were
appointed by the uh appointed by the
court they were appointed with no
qualifications with no training with no
standards and with no process for
discipline for
misbehavior the guardian item board was
created and over the last 20 years those
have been those practices have been
established and we have a guardian elems
who are all certified qualified trained
continuously trained and providing
services to the state of New
Hampshire the
the uh the issue here is uh you the the
way this is
proposed uh the commission is going to
look at this uh and it'd have to look at
it within a year in fact it might be
less than a year because it would all
depend on when the governor signs the
bill because the bill will be effective
when the governor signs it it might not
be before July 1st 202 before and so in
any event uh it's only one year so look
at it this way if the commission doesn't
act in one year the guardian lightning
board goes away who's taking over those
responsibilities if you said well
somebody else has to do that well who's
going to do that maybe the courts would
have to do that but if they did that
they'd have to do the same thing the
garden board's already done put in rules
establish rules in the court
system require training provide training
the way the guardian liem board's done
do all of those things so one year is
just frankly
absurd and it appears uh just just
absurd just doesn't work so even if you
were to say it has to be repealed you
should at least give it 3 years five
years some some reasonable period of
time one year is just ridiculous
okay
the just uh and so I'm asking that I
first the the other thing is I just ask
you not to repeal it but uh I think you
have to look at that in terms of the
whole
bill the other looking back at the idea
creating the
commission and I think the point was
just made by representative Smith and
that is you look at these commissions
these are these are commissions in here
you know aren't going to be repealed
there might be some changes but they
aren't going to be
repealed uh my suggestion is put your
commission in place for two years and
pick the boards and
commissions that you think have the
greatest need and they frankly they've
already done that for you because
they've taken one and two uh if you look
at section one and two under the repeals
obviously Somebody went through that and
said because it the quickest ones to be
repealed somebody thinks those are the
ones that ought to be
repealed so I think if you go through
and say okay we're going to establish
commission for two years we're going to
look at those commissions they have to
do that in that two-year period of
time and they they're the ones that have
to make the change and frankly repeal
the commission at the end of two years
so that's where the repeal ought to
be okay and the the last comment that
I'd have is a comment with regard to the
membership of the
committee and I'm speaking as a private
citizen today by the way but uh so no
offense to
legislators but has three members of the
legislature appointed by the house three
three members of the legislator
appointed by the Senate President you
know you've got a majority uh in essence
not a majority but uh a large group of
legislators what concern me as a private
citizen
is who are the legislators to actually
be qualified to decide these boards
aren't you better to find people who
would call with some appointee from the
business and industry Association be
somebody better to make an analysis of
the effectiveness of boards the cost
Effectiveness and of oplc which I think
has its own
issues so uh I think I if I were looking
at C and I can tell you on this on the
we have some issues with regard to
getting a quorum at the guardian lighten
board we meet usually but usually what
our biggest problem is is getting the
two legislators the senator and the and
the rep there to show
up
okay and if they showed up more often
qum wouldn't be as much of a problem for
us so uh and so I would think that you
want to have people if you're going to
run this commission you'd want to have
people who are qualified on the
commission not just because they're
legislators because as a private citizen
I'm going to say with six legislators on
there this is going to be a political
commission not not a commission directed
at resolving the problem that's intended
to be
resolved okay those are my thoughts
thank you are there any
questions thank oh representative
Moody thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
Gordon for taking my question
um your last statement confirmed my
doubt in terms of this commission would
be very politically driven because
there's a
heavy more members of legislation than
the people in profession or from common
things so that would impact every two
years like we have in New Hampshire
would you agree with that so the
productivity of this board or this
commission I should
say would be a
issue well um my bigger concern I think
the concern was raised earlier about the
predictability of who's going to be in
power and conquered at any given time
and how that affects legislation and
what gets accomplished so that's my my
biggest concern and that's one of the
reasons why I think the commission
should when you create this commission
you should put it into effect not
forever but for two years with a sunset
pick particular boards that you think
probably should be addressed are you
going to do away with a real estate
board no you know if you think you ought
to study the real estate board study the
real estate board but I don't think you
need to I don't think there's any
purpose in the world of saying okay
we've got a sunset that today
the Board of Medicine are you going to
Sunset the Board of Medicine does that
make any sense to anybody doesn't make
any sense to me and I don't think it
makes much sense to most of the people
in the
state thank you sir thank you everybody
um next and it's my old eyes I see
coretti and something with an H is
okay thank you Mr
coretti
thank you my name is Glee corsetti
Hooper I'm the public member on the
naturopathic Board of
examiners and I don't really have a yay
or nay on this bill because I don't I
didn't really understand it when I read
it but I was very concerned about the
repeal and I guess I have a few three
questions
um one
is uh just before I got on the board I'm
serving my second term so I've been on
for six years and I have four more years
uh we had an audit and so we spent at
least two or three years addressing all
the concerns of the audit and I don't
even exactly know who did the audit I
don't know if it was jail car or who it
was but I guess I'm
wondering um you know do all the boards
get audited and if this is some
replacement for auditing um that was a
very
specific uh look at the statute and what
we were missing in statute and rules and
whatnot and we addressed all those
things and and so there was that um I
just want to comment on that I also want
to comment on the governor's
appointments of people because when I
recently got reappointed I found out
from the young lady who works for
governor Nunu that the public member on
the board of natural Catholic examiners
is one of the public members that's
appointed only by the governor so it
took a long time and then she was able
to sort of expedited when I called other
public members of support are appointed
by the governor and then have to be
approved by the executive committee so
um it seems to
me you know knowing who how and who the
governor appoints and who's involved in
all that process would be useful and
maybe
standardized um and then the third thing
is that I'm aware of um a sunset law in
in Florida which was the first state in
the country to license naturopathic
doctors and you know it's a small
profession I think it's extremely
important for the public and the
well-being and health and benefits of
the people of the state and
um as as far as I know right now there
are somewhere between 115 and 120
naturopaths in the state of New
Hampshire so and they're all you know up
to their eyeballs and busy patient care
and they don't have lob you know they
have one lobbyist that works for the
State Association and they
um they would have you know a difficult
time
um I think mounting the support that
they would need to try to deal with some
some kind of repeal if that were to
happen um
so in New in Florida the law Sunset it
never did get reenacted and they don't
have naturopathic doctors down there um
so that's what happened there and I
would really hate to see that happen
here I you know personally have been the
beneficiary of naturopathic medicine for
about well I was involved in the
hearings when the log up passed about 26
or S years ago and um I was the
president of the Autism Society for 10
years and raised a son on the autism so
on spectrum and was hugely helped by the
guidance and benefit you know from the
naturopathic doctors that I saw here and
still do so I guess that's just all I
wanted to say and I thank you very much
and if anybody has any questions I'd be
happy to are are there any
questions oh representative Brown um
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my question could could you just repeat
what you said about Florida so that I'm
sure I understood that they had a
similar legislation and it caused well
Florida I don't know the details of this
I just know from the naturopaths that
I've spoken to that Florida I think was
the first state in the nation to license
naturopaths as doctors um and you know
they go to four years of postgraduate
medical Medical school and whatnot and
then the the law Sunset and the
profession wasn't up and aable to you
know reintroduce legislation I don't
know how or why that happened but there
are no licensed naturopaths in Florida
now thank you that's what I understand
thank
you anything
else thank you thank you so
much uh Edward
David
pardon me Mr chair I'm Charles poell I'm
also on the board of accountancy along
with our chair at da Davis if I could
join at this time I think it might be
sounds very functional yes thank
you good afternoon and thank you for uh
listening to us um my name is Ed David I
live in cab Brook I'm a CPA and I'm the
current chair of the board of
accountancy I request that this
committee rejects the bill as relates to
the sunset of the boards as I understand
this bill written in English I do
understand English absent any changes
the board of accountancy will sunset 71
2026 no ifs ands about it that is what
is written I believe that our board
provides oversight and helps to protect
the Commerce within the state of New
Hampshire this bill will eliminate the
oversight which ultimately could harm
the public and other users of financial
statements and tax
returns that also includes Department of
Revenue as far as state tax returns
being filed
timely again I humbly request that this
committee rejects the bill as it will
diminish the protection of the public
thank
you good afternoon again Charles pal
from the board of accountancy uh Mr
chair members of the committee thank you
for allowing me to speak once again
today with regard to House Bill 16
76 uh I have also submitted uh written
comments in opposition and those should
be before
you I had many many remarks when this
hearing started but so many people have
repeated what I would have said that I
don't want to belabor the issues too
much I would go simply um to this uh
concern in this
bill uh the default is repeal and I
think that that is an extremely risky
gamut I'm I'm reminded as I sit here of
an old saying that I've heard many many
times if you want to hear God laugh just
tell him your plans and my concern here
is that um the
commission and this has been recognized
as being uh a risk of commissions will
not act in a timely fashion and bills
will be repealed including
the statutory Authority for the board of
accountancy I can tell you that I have
served I'm a public member on the board
I'm not an accountant and I have served
on the board for going on three years
now I have been impressed from the
beginning with the enthusiasm and
professionalism of the members of our
board both public members and accountant
members uh we to my recollection and I
think Ed would support me on this we
have never lacked a quorum for a meeting
whether it was a normally scheduled
meeting or a special meeting called on
an emergency basis such as we had this
morning at 8:15 a.m. to discuss the
various legislation that's being
considered by this committee I think it
would be a travesty for the authority of
the board of accountancy to be repealed
whether on purpose or by accident
through inaction and I just wanted to
express those concern concerns to the
committee here today of course I thank
you for allowing uh me to speak and I'm
perfectly willing to entertain any
questions that any of you may have are
there any
questions representative Brown uh thank
you Mr chair you might be able to answer
what I started asking much earlier in
this um do you feel that
there's reason to review these
boards on some
timely basis with with without having a
repeal piece but let's make the
assumption that the conversation we
should review these boards regardless of
how we force the commission to do it
but my answer to that is simple I think
that a review of existing boards is
appropriate whether or not it's
necessary at this point in time I don't
know but I can tell you this I think
that as legislators that is probably the
type of thing that you want to review on
a regular basis if you will to make sure
that needs are being met the problem
that the board sees the major problem
that the board the board of accountancy
sees with this bill is the uh repeal by
default which is very very dangerous we
think thank
you as a followup I my only point I
would like to add to that is I think
oplc would be able
to identify those boards that are not
performing so you would would actually
highlight the ones that need help and
assistance before you go through all
44 representative
Gould hi thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question don't you
think that would put a lot of burden on
oplc and create a hostile environment
within the
office yeah it already is no no actually
we have a great work and relationship
with oplc and I I think think if um you
know Courtney came to us and expressed
unhappiness with certain things what we
were doing as a board we would certainly
address them I know myself now as the
chair we would address them may I
briefly uh add a comment to that
certainly one of the things that we have
um discussed at the board among many is
the fact that we are Revenue net
positive um by I don't know the numbers
exactly but by a substantial Yeah by a
substantial amount so I think that oplc
at least with regard to the board of
accountancy is um is satisfied with with
our performance and certainly we've
shown our enthusiasm for the work that
we do by our attendance and um ability
to address any issues as they come up
thank you
followup yes go ahead thank you Mr
chair I thank you for that answer and I
hear from you the good work that you're
doing and the relationship you have and
I think uh it's been said before we hear
from a lot of the boards on a lot of
different bills and we see the good work
people are doing it's um I look forward
to the work of the subcommittee on uh on
some of the language perhaps but I think
that that the fear that's been created
by the word
repeal uh which was intended as a carrot
on a stick to motivate people to get a
review done is unnecessary because you
all doing great work thank you thank
thank you so
much thank you
gentlemen uh Philip
[Music]
Sherman thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee uh my name is Philip
Sherman and I'm a the chair of the
building code review board I'm also a
licensed professional engineer but
speaking today about the
bcrb uh I speak in a highly respectful
opposition to this bill particularly the
part on on the default to repealing this
bill proposes the sunset the board of
Architects the board of home inspectors
the Board of Professional Engineers the
electricians board the installation
Standards Board related to manufactured
housing and the mechanical licensing
board unless the legislature introduces
A legislature introduces new legislation
to continue or recreate the board each
board disappears each of these boards is
part of the complex system that supports
Building Safety in the state and the
state building code is one of the major
pieces of this very complex system six
of these boards nominate members to the
of to our 17 member building code review
board so I respectfully suggest that
defaulting to the elimination of these
boards as part of a longer list of
boards runs the risk that something
slows down the replacement process and
the implications Cascade through the
building safety process a better
approach would be to continue the boards
on which there are General agreement
unless the legislature chooses to
specifically eliminate them happy to
answer any
questions are there any
questions representative Brown uh thank
you uh Mr chair maybe it's getting late
in the day here I am asking for
clarification again can you repeat what
you said several of the boards provide
S Suggest our board consists of 16
members nominated by what I'll call
constituent groups uh various portions
of the building industry and then
appointed by the commissioner of safety
plus myself as a 17th member appointed
by the commissioner six of those 16 uh
constituent groups are represented by
Boards on this list got it thank
you thank you thank you uh Jody
Bell good afternoon thank you Mr chair
and house executive department and
administration committee members thank
you for this opportunity to share our
perspective my name is jod Bell I am a
licensed acupuncturist here in New
Hampshire I serve on the New Hampshire
Board of acupuncture licensing but I am
here today as a member of our state
professional association representing
the New Hampshire acupuncture and Asian
medicine Association also referred to as
nahama so I agree with many of those who
have expressed opposition today very
thorough and specific especially
regarding Miss Cooper's mention of an
audit that was something that our board
went through which was very ful and we
did it and it was fine so I wish to
present our letter to the committee
demonstrating our association stand on
HB 1676 FN currently on the agenda I
believe you all have a copy of that in
your
possession I'll just skip to the meat of
it it is the position of the New
Hampshire acupuncture and Asian medicine
Association Nama that the sunset
commission proposed by hb1 1676 FN is
not necess necessary it is in our
opinion it is redundant wasteful and neg
negligent for Public Safety it is
difficult to imagine members of the
House are looking for ways that a person
could practice in a health care field
such as acupuncture that is below the
National Standard of our profession or
Worse without the need of a license or
even without a superv supervisory board
if allowed to pass these are possible
outcomes of hb1 1676 FN the board of
acupunctural licensing has done its due
diligence since its Inception of our
license in 1997 and is assured that New
Hampshire practitioners meet
professionalism ethics and safety levels
as set forth by the national
certification commission for acupuncture
and Oriental medicine which protects the
practitioner and the public over the
past two years alone the board of
acupuncture has worked with opsc to
clarify language in the RSA and create
rules and guidelines that Auto aate the
online licensing of acupuncturist in our
state these measures are in step with
other licensed professions the
acupuncture board creates more ways to
show competency and education which
opens the license to acupuncturists who
are not only trained outside of the
US but also train nationally without
loosening the standards we've already
done this work so some may argue for
loosening standards because there have
been very few negative incidences in the
state showing that acup puncture is a
low-risk profession however nahama
maintains that there have been very few
incidences of concern because of the
high standards of practice and the
acupuncture Board of our
peers nahama believes the sunset
commission creates an unnecessary
redundancy work already completed as
stated in the bill the real purpose is
find ways to loosen the standards for
more practice of a profession in a state
intended to increase employment
M another is to reduce cost it seems the
focus of the hb1 1676 FN is more about
reducing costs than protecting Public
Safety it is best to have a board that
keeps the pulse on the profession of for
a higher standard of care currently the
cost is $25 per person per meeting with
an average of four meetings per year
that's for the acupuncture board I'm
sure other boards are way different as
I'm hearing this p last year if all five
members attended all five sessions the
highest amount would be
$625 unless this committee agrees that
the following possible outcomes are
beneficial such as loosening
Professional Standards of Health Care
improves Public Safety that removing an
Advisory Board appear peers within a
profession then turns the
decision-making process to a body that
does not fully understand the extent of
Education and Training necessary to be
safe and effective practitioner and if 5
00 to $625 is an extreme cost for board
oversight then you must oppose hb1
1676 FN thank you for your attention to
this matter very respectfully Jody
any questions representative manui thank
you Mr chair a quick question how the
repeal of the board and repeal of
Licensing would affect your
reimbursement
structure thank you for that question um
we are considered without a license
insurance companies could not be paying
us we would just be random people on the
street doing our profession and not
having any legitimacy in the insurance
world thank
you all right thank you all
right uh AR Gordon
ladyy
thank you good afternoon um Mr chairman
members of the committee uh my name is
Gordon Ley and I am I live in Amherst um
and I'm chair of the New Hampshire Board
of Landscape Architects um I'm here to
speak in opposition to this bill uh
regulation of profession practice as
we've heard in medicine design
construction all exists not to pose a
barrier to entry to the
profession um or stake a Turf for some
business it uh is to ensure that
professionals have the requisite
education training and experience to
practice their profession and ensure the
health safety and Welfare of the
citizens of the state so that's the
bottom line is that it's a police power
that has been adopted in virtually every
state for a variety of
professions um including landscape
architecture professional licensure
regulated by the state ensures that
lenses have been found to be minimally
competent to practice their profession
is determined by education experience
and
examination I'm proud to say that I've
been found minimally competent in um in
10 or 12 states of the United States um
our board's rules permit simple rep
reciprocity granted by administrative
review if a practitioner is licensed in
another jurisdiction with similar
licensing requirements so that's no
barrier to it's a it's a very simple
process that occurs quickly uh without
needing to wait for a uh a meeting of
the board Most states have requirements
similar to New Hampshire so it's it is
as I said very simple elimination of L
insure would pose a burden on
practitioners in New Hampshire since
gaining those reciprocal licenses in
other states we're a small region and we
typically practice across state lines
would be impossible it also would affect
uh New Hampshire practitioners from
being able to obtain uh insurance and uh
and federal contracts for example U all
of which require uh professional
licensure um in addition Market
competition or civil action are uh poor
uh methods of regulating professions
since people need to be show harm in
order to have any any action take place
and the goal here is to prevent
harm
um so notwithstanding testimony we've
heard today HB 16 76 requires
elimination of licenses for a variety of
professionals on a on a rolling basis
over the next seven years starting July
1 2025 irrespective of the findings of
the commission so the commission may do
their work make findings but the
commission is not responsible to make
changes to
law this body is responsible to make
changes to law and I stopped predicting
the actions of the legislature a long
long time ago so I urge the uh the the
committee to find HP 1676 inexpedient to
legislate uh please do not approve this
abreg of the state's responsibility to
protect the health safety and Welfare of
its citizens thank you very much for
taking my testimony and I'd be happy to
answer any questions you might have are
there any
questions thank you thank you
sir Lee
McGrath Mr
chair could oh you had a quit oh no not
uh process question can we can we finish
passing on all the paperwork before we
have anyone else talk because it's
getting distracting to me I'm sorry
that's my fault and it's I promise you
I'm finished sorry
okay welcome Mr McGrath thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is Lee McGrath I'm legisl I'm an
attorney at The Institute for for J
Justice uh thank you for the opportunity
to voice my colleagues and my support
for this very this important piece of
legislation House Bill
1676 Sunset reviews are not
new they have existed since the early
1970s but to a large extent they have
been
impotent because the status quo prevails
and it's it's for that reason that
representative leakas is right to
include put the burden on those
advocating for the status status quo
when you pass a crime a a a new crime
law when you pass a new tort law you
identify who has the burden of proof in
criminal law you put that burden on the
government that you say that the
government must prove Beyond reasonable
doubt that the person did the crime in a
tort you put that that in a civil action
you put that burden on the government by
a
preponderance of of EV evidence
51% at the core of this bill is New
Hampshire's constitutional right to
obtain happiness in article in Article 2
of part one of your
Constitution obtaining happiness is that
Jeffers matoni and I Jeffersonian idea
of realizing one's full po potential and
you recognized it I don't know if you
did it before Madison or you did it or
Jefferson but you did it a or whether
you did it after Madison and Jefferson
but you recognize the importance of
one's entering the labor market entering
being able to work being able to pursue
the their career and so it follows that
the burden should be on those
obstructing that right for those that
who want to infringe upon those those
rights who want to make it more
difficult to to
work so the burden should be on those
who are advocating
now Most states do what this what some
testifiers have suggested don't have
that default that's in this bill but
Texas does and so does Ohio in Texas
this over it was put in in 1977 and over
that that time the CPAs have come before
the Texas uh Sunset commission and had
their bill their their license renewed
three times and so the one should be
temperate in believing that this is the
end of the
world and to that extent let me thank
representative ghoul for pointing out on
page two line 35 and 36 the word on line
35 the word
or on line 35 reads reflects other
recommendations to the legislature or
make no cha no changes so this is a
process bill it it puts in front of this
Commission on a regular
basis the review the
review of certain certain regulations
with no implied the word or does not
imply Destiny it implies Flex
flexibility no board no law should be a
sacred cow and reviewing them
periodically is very very important let
me go to my second and final point which
is what this bill does particularly well
is say that you do not live in a binary
world you do not live in a world of
license versus no Li Li license you do
not live in a world of binary world of
exist aboard exist or doesn't exist you
what this bill does on page number two
is point out that you live in a world in
which you have lots of regulatory
choices on p on line nine you could let
Market forces you could let Yelp and
other review and reputation and word of
Word of Mouth be the regulatory force on
line 25 you could let occupational
licenses be the regulatory force and
between those two lines you have lots of
choices let me point out line 17 on page
two and line 18 the regulation of
facilities where specific goods or
services is
sold and
inspections the radical thing of putting
food in your mouth at restaurants is not
regulated by an occupational license The
Cook the chef the bus boy the purchasing
agent does not need to be licensed in
the state of of New Hampshire instead
your municipalities regularly inspect
restaurants and that is the right
proportional type of reg regulation that
should exist for
restaurants and what it invites you what
this bill does it invites the commission
to think about what is the proportional
type of Regulation to those risks and it
does it in a very important
way much is often said of cost benefit
analysis but the problem is there's just
not enough data that exists as to what
the costs are for certain license what
the benefits are for certain license and
so what that tends to do it tends to
invite advocates for licensing to come
forward with exaggerated anecdotes and
unsubstantiated points about health and
safety you're very experienced
legislators you know the problem of
public Cho choice where those with
concentrated benefits show up this
bill this bill is a vehicle for your
review in ways that are
systematic that allow that ensure that
the problems of regulatory capture and
public Choice are not overly overly
influ influential to and stop Granite
Staters from pursuing their they're
calling
finally Mr chairman members what this
bill also does on page three on
line8 is to
invite the commission to seek expertise
on antitrust law occupational licensing
the Federal Trade Commission sued the
the North Carolina Dental Board in
2014 and it and the Supreme Court found
that occupational licensing boards can
be problematic because they can be
captured and participants on that board
can extend their their Authority beyond
what has been delegated to them by the
legislature and that exposes that
exposed the state of North Carolina and
by proxy the state of uh of new New
Hampshire to
litigation I submit to you that this is
a moderate process bill that puts the
right burden on those on the status
quo but it's a burden of only 51% of the
members it is not a big it is not a big
burden and there are plenty of people
available to to
support
the renewal of regulations when they are
reviewed and
Justified on behalf of my colleagues at
The Institute for justice I
applaud representative ghoul
representative lakus representative
Maguire and and others and I appreciate
the time to talk about trying to make
New Hampshire a little Freer so for
those who want to pursue their
constitutional rights to obtain
happiness thank
you are there any
questions thank you
sir is there anyone else who would like
to
speak then I guess I can adjourn the
meeting thank you
it's